[Music]
[Laughter]
i ain't seen the sunshine since i don't
know when i'm stuck in folsom prison
yeah and i can be free
as soon as that video came on us
and as was bothering me
yeah got a little johnny cash to open
the show today yeah going down down down
in a burning ring of fire man i love
that song
it burns burns burns that ring of fire
it's about vd that ring
i'm surprised they never use i know
that's terrible but i'm surprised they
never used that song in like a
preparation age commercial do they still
do they still make preparation h hi you
guys
we're talking about fiery buttholes
uh yeah sandra made a rug out of tom's
back hair that's what he says yeah
um
probably we should have
that [ __ ] better being that [ __ ] better
be like
macrame with like a [ __ ] pattern in
it and [ __ ]
[ __ ] macrame yeah
my mom taught me how to macrame when i
was little yeah this [ __ ] better be
beautiful i made a owl and everything
everybody had like this [ __ ] hook
thing that goes through the pool well no
that's that's uh that's latch hooks i
know how to do that too that's much
easier
um because they just have a tool for
that basically it's just kind of like
you have a it's like a it's not even
materials really it's just kind of like
this plasticy that with you know big
holes in it and then it has this little
uh this little tool
i said little tool um that's kind of
like you just put this little piece of
yarn through it and you go chunk and it
like ties a knot in it yeah so it's that
macrame is kind of similar but you just
do it you do it with your hands you
don't have a tool for macrame i don't
think
but yeah
what's the name of the pb what you
talking about we getting talking about
the peanut butter she must be talking oh
she must be talking to somebody else
about peanut butter
yeah right peanut butter yeah oh tila's
in there what's up t hey everybody says
she's gonna be in and out
all right
oracle says latch hooking is the paint
by numbers of the fiber arts world
exactly exactly you used to be able to
you probably can i don't know if you can
anymore but you used to be able when i
was a kid you could buy like latch hook
kits right alongside the paint by number
kids yeah which i used to like those
even though i can paint for real um
you know it's they were just kind of fun
they're sort of relaxing grant's saying
one of our high school teachers died
which one died
oh [ __ ] i've gone to the big high school
on this guy
wouldn't that be terrible if like you
were a teacher your whole life and then
you died and you're like wait this is
having [ __ ] this remember a social
studies teacher we had that one dude he
had that [ __ ] pickle he was he had
that [ __ ] polish name and that
[ __ ] terrible
his [ __ ] nose looked like a damn
when it was carpenter [ __ ] squares
that [ __ ] went out like that from where
that dude's name was he was [ __ ] mean
man he's real mean but he he predicted
the future
he went out there and he goes i know all
you guys all your parents work for ford
and gm and all that's over all that's
going to china there's no reason for you
guys to be making that kind of money you
know but uh he's sucking something else
man he goes well that was kind of
starting to happen yeah this is all
going to be a service industry you're
going to be making money at
mcdonald's and denny's and you know
service industries the future you don't
want those jobs those jobs are dirty you
die early you don't want that let the
chinese do that
and and he was right that's exactly what
happened
and they're like ah detroit that's going
to vanish [ __ ] was nostra [ __ ]
dominance yeah yeah yeah or nostra
thomas yeah
grand there's hammer said mr matthews is
that his name taught chemistry no no no
not that guy oh the one that died he's
the one the one that died yeah right i
was talking about some dude is like
you know how they all had them damn
names that ended with ski or jack
or or check on the back of them ski or
czech kowalski and nova check i think a
name well yeah because there's a lot of
like eastern europe yeah yeah
immigrants and stuff yeah looking back
on it that dude was probably part of the
communist party or something because he
was real [ __ ] but he would
yeah
but the real communist party
hell yeah i'm not talking about this
[ __ ] pale imitation for comedies like
you have to date all these little
[ __ ] you know effeminate
[ __ ] he was [ __ ] manly and
he was mean he was real mean
he was like one of those right-wing
[ __ ]
right-wing fascist commies you know
[ __ ] where you know
like the soviet union had you know they
picked up guns and [ __ ]
you obeyed her they killed you he was
one of those kind of guys
he probably remembers who was out i had
a high school teacher kind of like yeah
i hated that [ __ ] yeah he wasn't
he
he probably grandma's prime members he
actually had he had no compunction at
all about using these mr martin
class
malinowski i think i might be right he
was one of those skis he was this mean
[ __ ] real mean i got a good
grade in that class though
but he was that's like your kind of guy
kind of he was yeah
i was real suspicious of him you know
esther said jenny you look so nice thank
you yeah i totally forgot i had this
shirt
he would show up he would he was like
one of the few teachers that would show
up in that [ __ ] would wear a suit
wearing a suit that is very suspicious
yeah yeah he was like a kgb agent or
something
although the main teacher i had in high
school always like weirdly wore kind of
like a cargo shirt sort of like low-key
hawaiian shirt kind of thing but he was
a similar kind of he was a similar kind
of vibe but he didn't wear a suit so he
was like incognito fascist yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] we got tom ross's evil
clone boobs
that's the name of that guy i hope
that's not a troll because that's like a
pretty good name
tt's going [ __ ] tom hitting all the
trigger words today
oh yeah i'm gonna trigger the [ __ ] out
of [ __ ] i'm gonna call it an
airstrike today that's the name of this
show well i told him like right before
because
you guys i don't know if you guys know
but we don't usually plan what we're
gonna talk about we're just like
drinking talk about whatever so i told
him so usually i'll put something like
working title or we don't know what the
[ __ ] we're doing edition or whatever so
i told tom as soon as he's like five
minutes before the show started i said
give me a funny title and he's like uh
tom calls in an airstrike and i was like
okay
i might change it later but i don't know
we'll see tom ross eva clone boobs says
high school grits test injections i'm
tom that's right
you got it [ __ ] you got it [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] off my chest he's got you [ __ ]
off my channel yeah why do you even need
to be here we have another one
high school in the sky for eternity
would be my version of hell that's the
same right that's what i'm thinking in
australia watching them sit around
watching the cops kill all the dogs
uh remember that don't kill dogs yeah
their [ __ ] cops are active don't kill
animals yeah
i mean kill all the people
i don't know exactly what you're talking
about if they're being [ __ ] but
don't kill the animals they don't know
anything about they kill the dogs
because they didn't want people going
outside
tom triggerfinger that's what i'm gonna
call you from here on out oh hell yeah
that's a pretty good that's a pretty
good name it's malinowski i think that's
what that dude's name was
and he was like uh he just kind of
reminded me of like
there's been like a couple of soviet
defectors you know over times like
[ __ ] oh what's his name
and uh little kgb defector and he was
like that but mean
um what's that guy's name
i can um you guys might remember what
i'm talking about he's the guy that did
those big courses back in the 80s on
subversion and psychological operations
what was that guy's name he did some
really cool [ __ ] he was like that
but he was he was he had kind of a dark
tone to him what was that fucker's name
um
[ __ ]
i'll think about it i'll remember it
later yeah like later i'll be talking
about something and getting all into it
and then he'll yell
yeah when you get old like you can't
remember [ __ ] like right away i could
probably i i i could probably remember
holding do you remember the other like
when we were doing the show the other
day and i could not remember the word
organs like your internal organs i was
like what are those things that are
under your skin you know yeah
i got a picture of him and that's him
right there
that's him right there
that [ __ ] how did you find a
picture of himself i had a picture of it
now i had a picture of that dude because
sometimes i'd post a picture of that
dude and that i'd make a fake
i'd put like a fake quote underneath it
every now and then that was like a year
or so back okay it was just funny you
know
like [ __ ] he would say
so this is how you've been spending your
time
i would send that [ __ ] to little swell
okay yeah
sandra said damn i miss everything here
because i'm googling for your peanut
butter yeah yuri desmond off cam guy
knew exactly that yuri besmanoff that
[ __ ] he was genius he talked
about his time he was interesting he
wrote a bunch of books and he did a
bunch of uh
talk shows and everything you talk about
what it was like to serve in the kgb
back in the back in the 80s he ran from
the kgb he said it was all [ __ ]
everything's basically they just trained
him a lot his job was just to lie to
foreigners really
about how great the soviet union was he
says you could show them pictures of
concentration camps they were killing
people and they would act and a
foreigner would actively deny that that
was going on and [ __ ] yuri was like
no no we were [ __ ] killing people
and uh he said that they'd walk people
to the gallows and they'd be sitting
there and [ __ ] spewing out communist
jargon while they were putting their
head in the damn
noose and hang them so they would they'd
be right up to their executions they
died as [ __ ] hardcore commies
believing in that [ __ ]
and the kgb didn't believe in it at all
they just used it as a weapon of mind
control against people that's what that
that's a really good really good shows
just listen to what he's talking about
akami never believes what he says he
just
says what he says to get power over you
they're like a nazi it's the same thing
jenny said uh oracle says jenny do you
know what the biggest organ for humans
is uh it's the skin i think although
sondra says for tom and jenny it's the
liver yeah i hope so
yeah otherwise we're in big trouble
[Laughter]
esther said she's going to be [ __ ] up
the trolls is the skin an organ yeah it
does count as an organ even though it's
more like a wrapper
that's like your packaging
yeah you know
it's the packaging
packaging
i'm just like i'm i'm in kind of an
amused mood because i was telling tom
about this
prior to uh starting the show but he's
like save it for the show save it for
the show he doesn't want to know so i
was just cause he does care yeah
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
no it's it's like a good topic i think
people might be interested in it and
they probably want to hear what you're
talking about well yeah so what i was
going to say and like why i'm kind of in
like a funny like a muse kind of salty
gory kind of mood i guess
so you guys know some of you guys uh
that are into like horror fiction and
stuff probably listen to my book reviews
right so i try to uh you know read a
book every week to review
so far i've succeeded so it's not even
try i'm let's you know
so
here's what happened
i did a tbr back in january and i had
this big pile of books and i said these
are all the ones that i'm gonna do this
year and it's like you know i'll
probably buy other ones and blah blah so
i bought this book
at a used bookstore in downtown sanford
like a long time ago like last like the
end of last year sometime
and i bought the book because i had
heard the author's name before but i
didn't think that i had read anything of
his or if i had i couldn't really
remember it all that well
so the book it's hardback but it was
like it was pretty cheap and i was like
yeah what the [ __ ] so i just like bought
it because i bought a bunch of books
because they were all like super cheap
so i bought it but then
i started thinking about it later
because i kind of worked through a bunch
of the books in my pile
and then i'm getting to this one and i'm
kind of like you know what i think the
reason that i remember that dude's name
is not because i had read something of
his before
it's because
i read this book i'm pretty sure this is
where i
knew it from i read this book a long
time ago i think i brought it up on the
show before especially when we were
talking about like um christian theme
parks and stuff i have this book called
rapture ready which is really funny and
it's kind of like about it's like a
journalist and he kind of goes
uh it's not undercover but he kind of
goes and investigates the world of like
christian entertainment
and i'm pretty sure that that's where i
heard this author's name before it's
frank peretti in case you guys didn't
know who is apparently like a really
successful
writer of christian fiction but i didn't
know that when i wrote this book because
blur when i bought this book because of
course i don't like really read the
description because i like to kind of go
into it
so
i start i open this book because i'm
like okay well i guess i'm gonna review
this one next week and like on that
literally the third page where he's like
doing all the thanks for whatever
research or whatever he thanks somebody
from the discovery institute or as
skeptics know it the discot
which is a creationist outfit and uh he
also thanked a person from like the
institute for creation science or
whatever and i was like oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] did i get myself into
so i was like well [ __ ] it you know what
um i'm just gonna read it anyway and
we'll see if it's any good now like the
first half of it it's essential it's
like a bigfoot novel it's like you know
it's
this couple they gotta go out on a
survival thing in the woods and the wife
uh spoiler alert gets kidnapped by a
bigfoot and uh then the husband is like
left like looking for her you know what
i mean
because at first they think it's a bear
and all this other stuff and i was
thinking you know this isn't too bad
it's you know what i mean it's just kind
of like every now and then there's like
some say some real like christiany stuff
and i was just kind of like okay but it
was you know most of it was just fine
and it was just like sasquatch and then
like about halfway through the book
all of a sudden bam [ __ ] creationist
propaganda
and i was just kind of like just hit you
with it out of the blue
make you want to go to the [ __ ] holy
land tour i kind of well i kind of knew
it was coming because like they he's not
like it's it's competently written yeah
but you could tell like he's the dude's
got some hobby horses that he wants to
ride and i know enough about because one
of my hobbies i don't know if you guys
know but i'm really into like
evolutionary biology genetics like all
that kind of stuff so it's like an
interest of mine so i've read like tons
of books on it so uh and i've i'm also
kind of interested in i haven't been
following in the last couple years but i
was also kind of interested in like all
the creationist and intelligent design
kind of [ __ ] and because i just
thought it was funny and uh so i know a
lot about their arguments so as soon as
i saw some of the characters like set up
i was kind of like oh okay i know where
this is going because i've heard
i've heard this song and dance before
and uh sure enough it did kind of go in
that direction and then at this point
i'm just kind of like you know what
okay so i have to record a review for a
book
by friday and i'm just kind of like do i
really want to finish this it's like i
really don't care enough about the
characters
to finish it and it's just kind of like
i don't know it pissed me off but i
don't know but i have read another books
that in the interim so i might review
that instead because that was like much
funnier and much better but
i don't know i might still do a review i
don't know if i want a review of this on
my channel because i'll get like all
these christian fiction fans coming over
like you know [ __ ] on me and stuff
but
i don't know i might do it just to like
make fun of it i don't know it's not a
terrible book it's still like kind of
entertaining but
i don't know getting halfway through the
[ __ ] and i was just kind of like ah and
like my eyes rolled back in my head even
though i kind of knew it was common
but i didn't expect it to be so
egregious i guess i thought it would be
more
because you know it's like it's supposed
to be like just a fun
supposed to be just like a fun bigfoot
monster book it's like why why you gotta
have an agenda like that i don't know
but it's just kind of like
i don't know i might still do a review
of it if you guys think it would be
funny but i like all the damn
christian [ __ ] i just do
i find it like funny i like it yeah
i find it funny yeah well it's just kind
of like scientology stuff
yeah which is also kind of but it's it's
weird because it's like funny but it
also like pisses me off at the same time
so it's like a weird what's what's the
word for being like amused and pissed
off at the same time is there a word for
that right
i was going to say i'm sure the germans
have one son
like that because you guys have words
for [ __ ] that doesn't exist that english
needs words for you know what i mean
because we don't have a word for it um
but you guys have one word for it even
though it's like a you know a super long
one like a compound word but that's what
that's one of the best things about
german i think is they're very good at
like expressing
concepts that that english doesn't
really have any words for well what's
funny is that english is more germanic
than german is in a way german has a lot
of latin influence in it and because of
that
it can get quite flowery
you know you can do certain things
english is real basic
i think kind of like legos you know talk
about you can just put things together
oracle just said that german is the lego
of languages
[Laughter]
english is more like i would say legos
though because uh
because
english is kind of limited and very
blocky it makes a very good scientific
language because there's very little
ambiguity in english in latin languages
you can play all kinds of games and
there's plenty of ambiguity although you
can do that in english too but
just a different way it doesn't sound as
good that's true it doesn't sound as
good you know and we do tend to and we
do tend to borrow words from other
languages if we don't have the right
word to express what we're like it's
just different portuguese and the latin
languages are a lot more flowery or a
lot more condensed and they're a lot
more uh they're they're a lot more
they're better for things like poetry
and music
um and and
for instance like you said i would have
gone you know i would have gone as three
words
in in portuguese that's only one word
yeah i would have gone yeah
yeah so you have the article the tense
and the verb all in
in in in one word that's conjugated yeah
well
german does that too
french also does that and there's male
and female that was mild and singular
and neutrals and stuff so there's a lot
of different things that you can do with
it
yeah
uh tila said how did the handmaid's tale
talk go pretty good actually there was
nine of us
so
you know some people talked more than
others but
you know i you know the host kind of uh
hadley thorne she had like a lot of uh
good questions prepared so that she kind
of went around and everybody got to talk
about the show and stuff like that so i
think it went i think she just put it up
earlier today so maybe i'll put like a
link says i sometimes listen to
christian talk radio in detroit it makes
me not want to hang with evangelicals
not that i have been just saying it's
it's i i i consider all that stuff to be
a genre oh thank you tom ross's evil
clone boobs okay yeah wait wait you gave
us some money go ahead yeah i have your
motorcycle key well that was my key yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's probably true we still don't know
where that kid is because they were
asking if i'd found the key no the ghost
has the key the poltergeist is still not
giving it back he's gone
i mean you know pop it out of the wall
come on i'll give it i gave up drop it
from the ceiling
i gave up
can't find it
i'm gonna buy another one it's gone i
don't know at least it's only 35 like i
said at least you have to pay like 200
bucks to get a couple of like extras
like i had to for my damn car i was
thinking about riding up there and
[ __ ] getting a replacement but it was
so [ __ ] hot today it's really hot
it's not um
very humid right now but it is hot here
in florida
i don't know man because like i go out
you know when i go out for my walks and
i try to go like really early like i'll
go like at seven in the morning or
something like that and still when i
come back i smell like like hot garbage
because it's just like so
[ __ ] it's full on dagobah right now
god damn it
god i hate august and it's it's
basically our monsoon season even though
it hasn't rained in a while
it rained a couple days ago yeah but it
used to rain every day in a good monsoon
yeah season it rained everything well i
i will say that hurricane season
actually doesn't end until the end of
november
and the worst months for hurricanes in
florida are september and october all
right
because at that point that hookup for
the outside because so much of the heat
has like soaked into the ocean that it's
like you know making more
and like you know they build up [ __ ]
power as they come across the ocean
and then they hit
you know but we haven't had one a while
but i don't want to
jinx it i don't believe in that but
did pookie eat it we thought about that
but i think it's too big for pookie to
eat we think she might have carried it
somewhere
but
i don't know or like hidden it because
she does do that like she carries her
little toys around and stuff
but
she has like a specified number of plays
she usually keeps her toys like under
the bed if you look under the under the
bed
she has this little there's a little
vast field of like all her little kitty
toys there's a couple in the closet too
because she likes to hang out in there i
checked one of the garbage cans the most
likely garbage can we're thrown into was
the one right next into the bathroom
yeah
and i i
i did check that
and it wasn't in there
i thought of that t
um i would have thrown it into the
kitchen one because they didn't pass
that
and
i couldn't find it
it's just weird
it is very weird and when i came in
thank you esther what does this say just
anything yeah just well no it's just
that's a nice donation thank you very
much i would have um
when i got off the bike the only thing
that would have been in my hand was that
was my helmet and the key
so there'd been no reason for me to
throw anything away i didn't have
anything with me
and the key usually goes in the pocket
or it pat it goes on
next to the sink in the bathroom or
it'll go to or it'll be on the uh what
you call it
the knights
stand or in front of the television if i
didn't leave it in in the ignition and i
usually leave it in the ignition because
i shut the garage door behind
open up the door
open the garage door
put the bike in on top of the mat what's
it pookie stop beating me up
[Laughter]
and then shut the garage door once it's
in place
what's up
girl she's down there by my feet pokey
pants i pull what you're asking for
she's like i don't know i just want to
know what you guys are doing in here
that's all you're on the shelf
i'm up here oh look
hello pocahontas yes
[Laughter]
yeah she's like okay i'll accept it from
you
she's like okay i'm getting down now
she's not real
she like she likes affection but if you
pick her up and put her in the lap she's
just like no no no no no she's she's not
you come down here on the floor get on
the floor that's over she's gonna walk
in circles around you
and and push on to you with your head if
you're on the floor she loves that
yeah she gets very excited if he because
he has like a little computer where he
plays like his old dune game
and it's on the floor like on the other
side of the bedroom by the window
normally keep it in the garage and then
when i want to play dune i [ __ ] break
it and just put it on the floor yeah
like an old video game yeah so he sits
there and plays it and i i swear to god
that like pookie can sense that daddy is
sitting on the floor because she'll come
running yeah from wherever she is she's
like oh my god yeah he's on the floor
and then she just like walks around
walks around watching her house
[Laughter]
or she jumps up on the windowsill and
goes behind the monitor and kind of yeah
i got the mouse on a metal pad but i'm
doing this playing the game and she
wants to put her nose in between the
mouse and the [ __ ] metal mouse pad
yeah
she's fighting with me with the mouse
she's like you need to be patting me
yeah yeah she's [ __ ] hilarious she
does that to me too like sometimes if
you know if you're not here or something
like that she'll come in my office she
busts the door open uh because the door
won't close all the way
so she busts the door open she jumps up
on that chair then she jumps up on the
arm of the chair and then she jumps up
on the little slidey thing that has the
you know that has the keyboard on it and
then she sticks her face underneath my
hand which is on the mouse she just goes
and then tries to walk around on
everything hold on to the carpet so i
don't pick her up oh no
she's like what
what what am i doing oh my god look
what's up with your little big eyes
pokey everybody wanted to see you see
oh what's up sweetie pie
she's [ __ ] hilarious
she's a clown
she's the only cat i've ever seen that
wrestles
yeah she's very wrestling she'll chase a
little bit but
she likes to wrestle
she likes to wrestle
don't you she i think she does yeah and
like i said she kind of follows you
everywhere too like hey what you doing
what you doing what you doing laying
around on her back with like a little
belly hanging out going what is like
totally she's part dog part monkey and
part human
man last night it was storming last
night
and she
really wanted to go out on the back
porch
and i was like pookie it's like raining
and lightning you don't want to go out
there she kept running around
tom and i was like laying up in bed like
watching some [ __ ] on netflix and she
kept like she would go to the window and
like go behind the curtain and look out
and then she'd come back around and then
she'd look at me and she'd be like
she's looking at the tablet and i was
just like you can't go outside it's
storming she can see the comments she's
looking at she was looking at herself on
my tablet yeah yeah i'll leave the tab
that running on the nightstand and i
have my earbuds in listening to some
podcast or something
and she'll get up on the bed
walk across my chest
and lean out and look at the damn
at the uh
at the tablet
you should download see the images you
should download one of those one of
those kitty specific apps like the ones
with like the little fishies that swim
around and kind of go in the thing i'll
be listening she'll probably really dig
it you know look and she's reaching out
and [ __ ] hitting it which hits pause
so stop
she tries to catch who's talking
she's like shut up so you can see
himself
[Laughter]
i think that's what she's doing she's
trying to like shut up whoever's talking
on your tablet
like i said we gave her her own tablet
which had like all the tape on it
because she likes to pull the tape off
but
she didn't uh she didn't like it she
likes your tablet yeah
she ha it has to be yours because we had
an old one and we're like hey hey here
you go poke and we gave her one like
with a bunch of tape on it she was like
nah [ __ ] that i want yours
i call her pookie pants
poopy pants well we call her lots of
different things she looks like she's
got pantaloons on
pookie pants well especially nowadays
because i mean she's i don't know like
if you guys know but she's uh a manx
yeah and um they don't she's fully grown
as far as i know yeah they don't get
much bigger than that um she's four four
and a half yeah she's yeah she turned
four in june
um and i think that's as big as they get
so she's like she's pretty small but
menks are kind of like they have like
little round heads little round bodies
and like little bitty short legs
so um and also she has
she has this thing where
she got fixed right and then the hair
grew back on her belly and the hair on
her belly grew back longer than the rest
of her hair
and we didn't cut it just because it was
so funny because it just looks like so
she has this little floof like on her
belly so when she runs
it kind of like flops back and forth
like that i don't think it's all fat it
might be some of it might be fat she's a
little bit fat
um tom calls her fat and i'm like shut
up don't call her that
sanders says that she just saw grizzly
man that'd be a good subject said the
one about the guy who got eaten oh man i
saw that isn't that isn't that the same
one yeah dude there's going to be verna
herzog made that yeah
i think it might be the same one i saw
that already that was one that was one
of the worst things that i ever like
listened like if you listen to like
the woman was screaming from getting
eaten too
he jumped in there to save his
girlfriend he ate both
he called it though he says if i get
eaten by a bear it's gonna be that one
over there and he'd saw that bear a
couple times yeah he wasn't dumb and
that bear came and ate him
[ __ ] man he was an old sick bear and you
know i mean he was running out of [ __ ]
to eat so you know
like i said about time to [ __ ] kill
something you know that dude couldn't
run from him
you can't reason with him you know what
i mean that your food
well yeah your bear's gotta eat you're
walking around you're just made of meat
what are you gonna be like walking just
you look like a big beef jerky well
young potato bears a healthy bear you
know
might find you amusing he's getting
plenty of food so he's not desperate you
know what i mean tila asked what we
thought about hairless cats
oh they're cool we uh remember that
woman that girl would bring one of one
to the club
yeah we uh we knew this girl that would
bring hers to um
uh will's pub will's pub yeah she'd let
it up on a table he was like he was
wearing a little shirt yeah he had a hat
she put a hat on him he liked it he
liked people he's like hey
what's going on they put him up on a
table and he'd [ __ ] you know let you
pat him and stuff he'd look around
wouldn't run anywhere and he'd get back
in her purse she'd carry him around
everywhere cute goth girl had her yeah
and yeah it was a boy i think but i
can't remember what his name was
uh
wasn't it named after one of the
gremlins
see that's what i thought
stripe or something like gizmo gizmo i
think it was gizmo i think it might have
been given
but um
he was a cool it wasn't like
he didn't act like a normal cat he acted
more a little bit he acted a lot smarter
than normal cat
like a normal cat would run if it was
panicked
and we're in a club we're in a crowded
club
well yeah there's like loud music and
yeah and he was just totally
yeah he was just like hey what's going
on everybody what's up everybody get up
on with these little clothes on yeah you
could pour some beer out he'd drink he'd
lap up a little bit of beer
remember that yeah for a little bit he's
lapping it up a little bit like yeah
and uh he would sit in her little purse
with his head popped up and he was hands
up he just watched where she was going
he didn't walk around she carried him
and he was just watching everything
happen wearing clothes
i remember he had a little shirt on yeah
yeah snakes had clothes on it was like
well i kind of feel like if you have a
sphinx i think they recommend because
normally you wouldn't recommend like
don't put clothes on your cat although
i'm tempted sometimes
but sphynx is i think they're like
you maybe put a little sweater on them
if you're like taking them outside
because they don't have any hair to keep
them warm
i don't think i've i've thought about
every now and then i kind of think to
myself i'm like we should get pookie a
halloween costume wouldn't that be cute
but
i kind of feel like she probably
wouldn't wear it it took us forever to
get her to wear a
collar
but she's good about the collar now like
she doesn't wear it all the time
but if she's gonna go out and sit on the
front or back porch i was just kind of
like well let's put the collar on her
just in case because it's reflective and
stuff and so everybody knows that that's
someone's cat if she wanders off
um
but it took us a while because for a
while you try to put it on her and she'd
be like no no no but now it's like she
knows that if she wants to go out on the
porch
um you kind of bring the the collar to
her and she'll be like okay and she'll
like sit there and go like that and let
you put the collar on her before she
goes outside
yeah graham says his friend is
said to shoot at the bears to remind him
to stay away type of deal over here none
of that [ __ ] works none of that would
work
here if the bears know you have food and
they're your friends they're just gonna
try to come hang out with you
if you see any videos from this area
and i'm talking about this area in this
neighborhood i have found some from here
in um actually it was either sanford or
it was up the street i believe
it was a small black bear and this old
dude and his wife he was trying to shoot
the goddamn little juvenile black bear
away
and that black bear grabbed him by the
[ __ ] knee and started wrestling with
him and rolling over and [ __ ] getting
slotted
he just thought he was playing
yeah yeah man you just you can't chase
off any of these bears they
well they've kind of [ __ ] you i live
here yeah they've been around here for
like forever so they're kind of like
used to people they're used to people
making noise they're used to being able
to like wander to people's garages and
like eat [ __ ] out of their fridge yeah
so you know and uh
his he was you know the dude that did
that this that was on youtube i saw the
video
and uh because i was looking for videos
of black bears in this area that was
during the time we start we were seeing
a bunch of them that was before the
black bear slaughter
that they did i remember that that made
me so sad yeah
and uh that video was a couple months
old when i found it and people were
mocking the old dude like dude what the
[ __ ] are you doing
i don't think he was from here
there was a bear in his backyard
or next to his driveway i think this is
kind of like his side yard and he goes
out there bowing up like a man like he's
a tough guy to chase off a young
juvenile black bear
and that black bear just
stood his ground you know it's the size
of a dog they're not that big
they weigh more than a dog they're a lot
more competent than a dog physically
and he's you get out of here you get out
here and that dog that bear just went
and crashing by the leg they're like
come down here oh man you know what i
mean and then
oh oh oh and he's trying to walk away
and [ __ ] the comments like you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing
i don't know why people get so upset i
mean the reason that i mean yes it could
happen that you stumble across like you
find a baby bear and like the mama gets
mad or whatever but most of the time i
feel like most of the people that have
been attacked around here
have
surprised the bear or tried to [ __ ] with
the bear yeah well they come out of
their house
into the throughout the garage and then
they wig out and they've trapped a bear
in the garage right and the bear tries
to get past them
the thing is though is the whole thing
about the cub stuff that's more [ __ ]
they're only the only ones that'll kill
you over a cup are like grizz
grizz and kodiak maybe a very large brow
bear
black bears are not defensive of their
cubs so there's all kinds of videos [ __ ]
that baby
so all kinds of
videos of them running up onto people's
porches trailing a bunch of cubs behind
them and hey give us something to eat
and they're just you know what you got
in there yeah and then the people coming
out feeding them and picking the baby
bears up wrestling with them the mama
doesn't give a [ __ ] and then there's a
lot of well they don't feel any threat
though i kind of feel like the only time
they're gonna i mean black bears at
least not other kind of bears but black
bears
at least around here the only time
they're gonna attack you is if they feel
threatened by it well yeah it well
there's also videos of damn animal
control grabbing the mama bear and the
baby bears at the same time and pulling
them and throwing them into damn cages
and [ __ ] and the mama doesn't really
show much concern one way or the other
she's just like let go
they don't freak out or anything they're
not
they run first and ask questions well
around here they're prettier around here
they're pretty chill it's black bear
they're scavengers
black bear are not aggressive
now does that mean a black bear won't
kill you oh yeah
well yeah that's what i mean if they
feel threatened by you they absolutely
will kill you and they are much bigger
and stronger i'm not even sure if it's
threatened
because the people that were killed by a
black bear were killed by single
large adult male black bears who
probably were just bad bears people who
understand bears he was just cranky yeah
he was good yeah they're an advanced
animal like anything else
there's variation between them they're
not clones they're not robots yes
you could come across a bad black bear
male
who will kill you
but that's not typical
even though most people killed by bear i
think are killed by black bear
but that does it's statistics
it's because black bear live around
humans
yeah you're more likely to run across a
bad black bear because he lives near you
you're not likely to run across a kodiak
that's something canada and [ __ ]
yeah that's that's what i mean the
population density i mean like i said we
live in an area that
although it's kind of
you know at one time it was rural but
now it's like pretty suburban and
honestly we're like what less than two
miles from the freeway yeah um so it's
kind of like you know there's a lot of
trees and woods and stuff but
i have seen
so we've lived here ten years i've seen
black bears all the time and not just in
the middle of the night i've seen him in
the middle of the night i've seen him in
the middle of the day
in the morning afternoon i just see him
like walking around the neighborhood
walking up people's driveways well a
couple miles in the other direction
though is woods that's true and the
woods go on for [ __ ] ever we're on
we're on the edge
that's that's a lot of a lot of it right
there
and uh they go where the food is they
know what garbage cans are yeah well
like i said that's why you have to in
this neighborhood you have to have like
the bear safe
the biggest bear i saw was just a couple
houses up the cops were there looking at
him and [ __ ] they were trying to
figure out what they were gonna do he
and that the cop knew that bear it had
been injured because they got hit by a
car years before and his back leg was
[ __ ] up
it never healed up properly and they
they eventually put him down because
they were afraid that he wasn't getting
enough food
i can understand that one
because he was
but they that time they killed seven
bears they told us but that bear was
huge
that pure bear was [ __ ] huge
if he were to stand up on his back legs
he'd probably be about eight feet tall
i mean [ __ ] much he was a big [ __ ]
much bigger than a man
so i think that's some of this [ __ ]
where sasquatch and [ __ ] comes from you
know what i mean a bear
these bears are huge some of them and
it's just a black bear
but he was probably pretty old you know
maybe 15 20 years old you know which is
probably pretty old for beer but you
know be big [ __ ] big i wouldn't want
to wrestle that thing even though
black bear are not really known for
being that aggressive
animals get aggressive when there's a
big size difference
you know what i mean between you and
them
there's no difference between a cat a
house cat and a lion there's that same
brain though the specialist
experts will tell you over and over
again
there's no difference between a house
cat a lion and a tiger
i'm convinced that
i'm convinced that beijing thinks that
she is a lion the different the reason
why
the only difference is the size
and that's why the bigger ones eat you
because they can
and they look at you and you they're
they're look a snack yeah well it's just
normal in in animals that well you're
smaller than me so it's my right to eat
you you're weak
it's you know it's a might make where it
might makes right thing
and um you don't want to be around an
animal that's bigger than you
you know even a horse will get pissed
it's much bigger than you to [ __ ]
kick you or bite you we'll see that's
white
well that's what i mean i'm not going to
get all like [ __ ] i know what i'm
doing
i'm not going to even around a horse or
something like that it's anything that
outweighs me by like several hundred
pounds and like can kick me and like
knock my head off yeah that's that's
cool i've handled it i will i've been
handling them since i was a kid
respectful this i've been handling them
since i was a kid i got pictures to
prove that [ __ ] i was a little [ __ ]
bitty kid jumping horses and [ __ ]
over the four and five feet and six foot
jumps
my mom was a champion out in california
back in the 70s yeah i don't know if
we've ever brought that up
for i got pictures of and [ __ ] but uh
yeah his mom's like a kind of a yeah she
was a horse trainer when i wasn't really
working my normal [ __ ] military type
[ __ ] or [ __ ] or [ __ ] cooking
then i'd go back into the [ __ ] horse
industry for a while well when i met you
you were still working out at that barn
like i was working at the time taking
care of the horses yeah i was taking
care of dr matt's horses yeah he's a
very wealthy dog he had a bunch of them
his mom built orlando general hospital
he's a very wealthy guy and his
house and his barn
was looked like something out of
disneyland
thank you mr roboto didn't want to let
that go he had a [ __ ] big his house
looked like the van southern version of
the [ __ ] haunted mansion and then he
had a barn with
six horses in it and then a bunch of
training round pins and yeah other
animals too he had some goats and a
bunch of chickens all kinds of stuff
yeah
so i took care of this place because you
know they don't have time for that [ __ ]
and i was also kind of like
security he was gone a lot all right and
you have you have to watch a place like
that it's like a multi-multi i liked it
i was it was a fun job it was a nice
place because like i said
yeah i would come and uh come with them
sometimes it's beautiful out on a
private road and everything you wouldn't
know it was there you'd have to find you
have to know it was there to find it
and it was like a southern colonial
mansion
and
and how many acres was that it was a big
it was a big property maybe ten
yeah it was a big problem and this is in
a suburban area yeah this is not in the
country and it's not that far from us
it's
i could walk there easily it's like
within walking distance it looked like
it was in the country but that's the way
it was built
there's a private road that led to it
and around it was the forest but that
was all on his property and it kind of
separates it from the rest of the
suburbs
so he was living in the country in the
middle of a suburb
well that's kind of the best thing to do
if you want like the experience of like
living oh i'm like roughing it and stuff
yeah but you still want to be able to
get to the grocery store yeah without
too much trouble he had he worked at the
hospital he ran this other little house
yeah oh my god i'm not gonna say which
hospital
he ran it wasn't the one his mom built
but but yeah we used to go to that
because i used to go with you to work
all the time it's like we used to go to
that uh that farm all the time still
there as far as i know yeah the only
downside in this in florida is that it's
[ __ ] hot
yes when you had to work there in the
summertime you gotta be like man i was
[ __ ] skinny as [ __ ] remember that
during that time you were yeah because i
was just burning so many calories
yeah because you're out there every day
like [ __ ] handling horses taking all
the horse again like riding all the
stalls riding them all around [ __ ] uh
putting them out in the pastures making
yeah
chickens yep had to [ __ ] get all the
eggs
get all the eggs because they had a
[ __ ] huge egg
[ __ ] chicken coop had to get all the
eggs and refrigerate all the eggs
because they had farm fresh eggs
and [ __ ] i got all the eggs i wanted
i got so i got sick of eggs
yeah because they were based they didn't
i know couldn't get all the eggs they
had yeah because they have a [ __ ] ton of
chickens and they were just kind of like
look they just keep laying eggs as
chickens do so it's just like take them
yeah so you constantly [ __ ] we had
like fridges full of eggs calling the
[ __ ] shoe and getting [ __ ] shoes
put on horses [ __ ] um
constantly [ __ ] grooming and washing
[ __ ] horses it's just a constant
rotation
and um
it was funny he didn't have any borders
they were all his family's horses
they were nice nice thoroughbreds and
stuff
uh he had an air he had one arab the
rest of them were all [ __ ] just
thoroughbreds
um they were beautiful right yeah
uh there's a pony there too wouldn't
they
yeah a long time remember he had that
goat named franklin yeah franklin
franklin i had a picture of franklin
somewhere and they head to turkey
yeah [ __ ] their turkey died i went
and grabbed a dead turkey and the
[ __ ] chickens attacked me they
thought i killed the turkey the turkey
was already dead
chickens are trying to tag me
they got all behind like bird
brotherhood yeah that's pretty cool but
uh somebody asked if you were the horse
whisperer
um no i i i know all about horse
whispering okay my mother's actually one
of the best she wrote in books on it and
everything her name is margie dumas
and uh
but uh no there's a trick to that you're
not whispering it has to do with body
language and round pen work and [ __ ]
using ropes and using hats
um
you're kind of manipulating a horse's
behavior by
normal body language and that's how
horses do it when they're in a a hurt
you know i mean it's just
you're trying to establish dominance
through their way which is
eye contact and body language and how
you pers how you position yourself
inside a pen or even an open space
you know
well it's just kind of like and we talk
about this in regards to pookie all the
time is that you know animals can't
really talk
uh to any great degree body language so
they use body language and positioning
to like tell you what they want or
certain tones of right to how to move
you yeah they move you or you move them
depending on where you're standing
there's a certain thing you know i mean
like you go over here then they go over
there if you come straight at them at
the shoulder then they go you're your
friend come straight at them through
their head then you're threatening them
because they don't do that others but
they have their own manners
you have to know what their manner yeah
you just have to like come at them from
their own right but like i said it's not
a mystery you can you can learn to do
that come in at the shoulder and grab
about a muscle and pull his head towards
you and blow in his ear just breathing
his nose breathing his nose i sometimes
do that all the time he would like
breathe the horse is [ __ ] like we're
sharing breath and [ __ ] and it looks
like they could all relax oh yes
i'm my friend that's their version of
msr
[Laughter]
just breathing each other's [ __ ] nose
breath
yeah
then after that you just [ __ ] walk
them around and they're like yeah you're
my friend
because
it's a different way of doing stuff
that's the way they communicate yeah
um
but you can do that almost with any
animal it's not just horses dogs are
similar uh i had i'd have no problem
with bears i could i saw how that one
dude was doing it i could do that
the difference is is
the real challenge would be things that
are cold-blooded like an alligator
they don't really communicate in the way
that that a mammal does yeah see i don't
know if i would really like trust my oh
what i got this yeah i'm gonna like talk
to this alligator it's more like dealing
with a robot that's why i wanted to get
a video of jenny to take a video of me
[ __ ] capturing a [ __ ] large
alligator or uh alternately i might get
an a video of you getting eaten by now
yeah one of the two but either way i
mean i might get a lot of views on that
[ __ ] so remember that
remember that dude i used to hang out
with he was uh
at
at ibar he was the bouncer and he ended
up being
at the at the [ __ ] oh right yeah yeah
he [ __ ] handles alligators now and
crocodiles remember that he was showing
show me all the videos of the [ __ ] he
was doing with alligators yeah
yeah well remember like when i was uh
when i was in st augustine back in june
and i went to the alligator farm which
you should go with me one time i love
the [ __ ] alligator farm i just love
it there and um the guy that worked
there
he was totally like standing and i guess
you know he he knows what to do and what
not to do
so he's standing i don't know if you
guys have never been to the alligator
farm in st augustine but there are like
i don't even know how many alligators
they have but it's uh it's a [ __ ] ton
okay it's a [ __ ] ton it's hundreds and
hundreds and they have this big huge
like lagoon which goes like all through
the [ __ ] uh park and he basically
just stands in there amid hundreds of
alligators and talks to everybody about
alligator behavior and this is blah blah
blah and it's like then he's like hey i
got this piece of food it's like whoa
here's this alligator that does this
kind of just like oh my god how does he
not get eaten i don't know it does
happen every now and then
um
that somebody gets you know because they
do something a little bit wrong
but
he's he that dude's still alive so you
know yeah grams are called farriers but
the average person doesn't know that so
i didn't use that terminology they're
called farrier guy who's uh
shoes horses
i've heard that term before yeah i used
to be like many teens like many teenage
girls in the 80s
i was super super into horses
and i always really wanted one but of
course my parents were broke so i
couldn't afford one but um
that's outgrabbed i had books about them
i had all this kind of stuff i was going
to show this to you man
a small ocean kg that's why he wanted to
call the video tom calls it an airstrike
because that's what he's going to use to
call in an airstrike a goddamn airstrike
can you not call in an airstrike on the
house though because i'm in it at the
moment we're calling an airstrike on
them damn trolls in the comment section
okay i'm ready i'm gonna let them let
them do their thing
yeah let's see how that goes
[Laughter]
it's uhf vhs gmrs and ham
and it can do am and fm but it can't
broadcast on those i don't think
i'm still going through the whole yes
i'm going to call in for a fire mission
foxtrot lima one niner distance
sierra romeo street gang fire mission oh
okay
wouldn't it be wouldn't it be funny if
like a helicopter flew over right now
and just like yeah yeah they haven't
answered yet i mean it wouldn't be if
they haven't answered yet yeah what is
your mission exactly yeah for our
mission the fire mission is to [ __ ]
call is call for fires does it have like
a main air strike does it have like a
cool like secret code name no they
haven't answered yet i was going to give
them a grid zone look location going to
do targeted are you going to blow me up
no i'm going to tell them where they are
on where their grids on the court where
their grid zone coordinates are that's
their location i was going to give a
target description and then i was going
to give a recommendation for [ __ ] he
all right which is high explosive and
then i was going to let them handle that
[ __ ] serpent surfer said this might be a
slight case of overbombing yeah right i
see what you did there
i don't have ham yet um
what it is is i have this thing on the
[ __ ] lowest setting i can also set it
for gmrs which you don't need to have a
license to broadcast in gmrs that's just
regular local
communication uh but i haven't taken the
ham test yet i don't know if i will i
mostly wanted to do it to monitor ham
we'll see how that goes
but i could always just use it for gmrs
this one's [ __ ] really good it's got
like four different power settings i
think it claims to be a 10 watt
um 10 watt
transceiver i think you know can
broadcast at 10 watts but but you can
lower it all the way down to one
and at one watt that [ __ ] that's what we
use for squad level radio in the army
at one watt
you wouldn't have to worry about a ham
license because you're not going to go
any further out than a mile just for
real local communications but i mostly
wanted it to scan
but it has a bunch of good [ __ ] you know
what i mean it came with an ear mic
low profile ear mic a regular microphone
for like police work
um you could use it just the mic that's
on here
and you can also get throat mics
waterproof throat mics for like [ __ ]
tactical [ __ ] it has vox capability
which is voice activated capability
um
so it's a good radio it's got a real
good monitor
[Music]
[Applause]
are we gonna get some evps
like some ghosts and [ __ ] are gonna like
talking through yeah yeah just like on
[ __ ] ghost adventures
isn't that essentially what that ghost
hunting thing is what is that thing
called what do they call that thing that
just essentially like scrolls through
all the like radio frequencies and it's
like we're asking it a question and then
it's like answering and it's ghosts that
are answering even though it's clearly
just like scrolling through the [ __ ]
stations and picking up words
grandfather's got his
fcc [ __ ] call sign
k-e-n-o-n
you reduce cb2 huh granthar's hammer
okay
this one can't transmit on cb
my dad used to do cb okay i wish i could
i wish i could remember what his handle
was
remember when that was like such a big
thing like in the 70s and early 80s like
everyone's cb handle like i think after
smoking the bandit like it kind of like
exploded somebody was like breaker one
nine blah blah blah they were all like
coming up with like some cool ass
[ __ ]
i think this is lazy ryder that's from
[ __ ] uh that's from that [ __ ]
movie though i think citizens band i
think citizens banned i think uh i think
truckers still use it well i'm sure they
do but this cell phone got rid of a lot
of that kind of [ __ ] even when you like
you don't need that [ __ ] anymore it's
just kind of like pay phones and watches
nobody needs that [ __ ] anymore no cb no
[ __ ] radio still has certain
applications especially
for very local communications you know
what i mean like if i want you to go
just over on the other side of the thing
and here just take this it's that kind
of deal
you set of different channels you can
also scramble and do weird things
i believe this one has scrambling so you
can get on the same frequency and then
you can put in the same
scramble codes between this radio and
another one like it
and if anybody else is on that frequency
they can't understand what you're saying
it's scrabbled but you but the two
but the two uh radios on the same
scrambling
i guess it's a it's a key can understand
each other that's that's a good idea
though
joke's on you i'm so deaf that i can't
understand what anybody's saying on
there anyway whether it's scrambled or
not it just sounds like
whatever it is you're saying tila said i
would love to see that video of tom
wrestling a gator please let's do that
yeah should we are you going okay
i'll do it wild gator if you take out a
life insurance policy first
no i wouldn't need one
that's what they all say i would just
choose one that was under six feet
they could still take off your whole
like they could pull your arm off though
and then you can bleed to death and it's
like i'm videotaping the [ __ ] i can't
alligator is most a lot of it's tail
all right yeah they're pretty strong uh
the the key would be to make sure that
he he can't get you out into into deep
water
you know what i mean
they roll they'll [ __ ] you up you want
to get him on land or in very shallow
water and pull them on land real quickly
you don't they're a lot stronger than
you in the water
they swim a lot better
and you don't want one to take you down
and drown you that's that's really the
the secret to it
well that's how they kill most of the
well that's how they kill a parade
that's much larger than themselves is
basically they just pull you and they're
strong enough to like keep you
underwater for the few minutes
you're having a big advantage over them
especially if you're you gotta grab them
by the nose and hold the whole jaw shut
at first i
straddle his head
and [ __ ] try to tape his [ __ ]
mouth closed and then you grab his
[ __ ]
leg his feet and put those behind him
and tape those together and pull him out
by his second tail and then you got him
that's how you catch him
my dad's friends would catch him all the
time this isn't some alien thing you
know what i mean
the problem is you don't want to do this
in deep water and especially
especially one that's way big big enough
to get a hold of you and take you out
into deep water you're through well i
mean that should be common sense right
you know
you'd be surprised they're also not i
would not be surprised
[Laughter]
try some stupid [ __ ] i would not be
surprised
there's a technique to do in it i just
hit the polish up on it i'd have to
remember exactly what i was told they
talked about all the time when i was a
kid but i'd have to polish up on it of
how it's done
um but no a lot of us [ __ ] just
knowing what not to do
and having balls
gotta have some [ __ ] big balls i told
you one of my favorite things from my
vacation like i said being at the
alligator farm was that as i said there
are several hundred alligators at this
place and they have this big huge lagoon
the guy he does like a demonstration
every day where he's like feeding them
and he's like talking about him and you
know and whatnot
they have a breeding program there and
whatnot and so he's standing there on
this little wooden
uh you know thing over the lagoon and
he's feeding them and the alligators all
know what's coming so they all like
hundreds of them like swim to this one
little central location and one of them
was totally this was like the baller of
the of the alligators that were all
there he was totally trying to climb up
into
you know it's like a wooden platform
with like you know logs and uh you know
barbed wire and shadow right so it
wasn't barbed wire it was like fence and
stuff but this one alligator
who really really wanted the food he was
really hungry i guess
but he crawled
most of the way up
and honestly
it looked like if an alligator was
determined enough they could probably
totally
crawl up over that [ __ ] which i wouldn't
have imagined i would have thought
i mean i know they can run faster than
people think i know you know obviously
they can swim really fast
but
this [ __ ]
he was basically like okay well i'm
gonna get up in this [ __ ] and he like
climbed over a couple of other ones and
he climbed most of the way like up this
log like on to this almost onto this
platform and then another alligator
jumped up and like kind of knocked him
down like hey [ __ ] like we're
all gonna eat what are you trying to do
um and you know so he got knocked back
but i think that if that hadn't happened
it looked like he very easily could have
like climbed up into that [ __ ] so
they're not
you know i know people say kind of like
oh we should run zigzag or whatever but
uh sidequest here says the ultimate
florida man articles always involve
someone doing stupid something stupid
with alligators yeah yeah like the guy
who threw the alligator through the
drive-through window i remember that was
it when was it wendy's yeah that's cool
though i think it was that way you know
that was cool you remembered it not so
cool for the people that were working at
wendy's at the time it's like dude i'm
just trying to like serve you a frosty
why are you throwing an alligator
through the window with me those dudes
that did that understood
the value of a [ __ ] prank
that was a [ __ ] prank you don't
expect to go to work
at mcdonald's and have a [ __ ]
four-foot alligator come through the
damn [ __ ] window yeah i'm pretty sure
well that [ __ ] would be hilarious live
in florida you might expect that
[Laughter]
you might expect that she would have
been hilarious
although you know
we've talked about animals the size of
animals
how animals
have gotten smaller over the years or
possibly have gotten i'm convinced
they're smaller now than they used to be
and
jeremy way to back me up on this i'm
gonna use his [ __ ] not
there was
old dudes it would have been my
granddad's age even though my granddad
died young
old dudes my of my granddad's generation
in mississippi
louisiana and louisiana that those areas
swore up and down
that when they were young kids
alligator gar
could get huge that they were [ __ ]
huge well they're not that small now
they're not small now
but they said that they were we're
talking about and that they were
dangerous
like great white
now
modern people would a day would say oh
[ __ ] that's not a very aggressive
fish it's a very primitive fish
a shark's primitive though
they're not yeah they're still pretty
efficient yeah they're not
i haven't seen them ever biting anybody
they look wicked as [ __ ]
experts some experts would say well what
it is they're reading into that creature
by its it's it's
its appearance because it's got a long
snout and it's got all those teeth
they're assuming that it's dangerous
they used to have [ __ ] paddle boats
go out with [ __ ] electric
nets on the front of them electrocuting
these damn things
that's not cool no
louisiana had a [ __ ] bounty out on
them trying back in the 20s trying to
wipe them out they were just there was
just so many of them
and people were scared of them but they
claimed just outrageous [ __ ] that
somebody i mean they do look like
[ __ ] but yeah barracudas look like
[ __ ] too and it does they will well
they will bite you but i mean
i think a lot of the [ __ ] too is like
barracudas
are dangerous but they're not as
dangerous as their reputation suggests i
think it's just because they look like
[ __ ] their little faces look like
[ __ ] things there were guys of my
granddad's generation that said that
when they were kids
out in the bio
in certain places in the mississippi
river
that people could be killed and eaten by
gar that were a bit bigger than 20 feet
long
and it makes you wonder i don't know i
don't doubt it if they got that big
maybe they would bite you
i mean um you know i've when snorkeling
i've seen some fairly large ones not 20
feet
but
i don't like i said i don't really see
anything and you know we've talked about
like river monsters and stuff like that
before it's just kind of like people
think about oh catfish there's just
little bitty things but one some of the
ones that jeremy wade has caught were
totally big enough
to at least swallow a dude's head
so
who's to say that at some point in the
past maybe in our grandparents
generation
uh there weren't like some alligator gar
that were
big enough to uh [ __ ] dude up i don't
doubt it
yeah i don't doubt it not for one second
that's not that's not crazy to think
because like i said i've been snorkeling
and i've seen some
fairly large ones not not one large
enough to kill you but one large enough
that
you know you might like think twice
about tangling with it y'all don't know
we're talking about a gar
is a is a fish i guess it's a fish it's
either a fish or an eel it's a fish it
is it's a very primitive fish though
there's not many other fish like it you
can look at one just google alligator
gar
they can still get very big maybe 12
feet
but reportedly they could get above 20
back in the day
i don't think they live long enough to
get that big anymore and there were
campaigns to wipe them out here in the
south
a bunch of different reasons you know
what i mean it might have been people
grifting
they had the ability to kill them and
they'd show up to the county and they
said these things are dangerous they're
eating the children paid me and i'll go
out there and kill them that might have
been partly what was going on i'm pretty
sure that's probably what it was they
did that with alligators though too but
alligators can't we're eating children
occasionally they one rallies out disney
a couple years back they did they'll
grab a child [ __ ] they're grabbing a
dog
yeah he was saving it for later i know
that's true yeah they literally they let
it they don't they can't chew
so
they'll drown a creature
and then put it up in its nest and let
it decay so it gets soft enough to where
they can pull it in pieces and swallow
it they they can't chew though
but they still they don't matter you're
dead they they [ __ ] drowned you they
could sit on the bottom for more than an
hour but i think at least 45 minutes
yeah a long time sale drowned you no
problem
um
they don't mean anything a guard looks
like that it looks like a [ __ ]
alligator with a with a neo body
and um
according to old dudes that should have
known
and i don't think they were bullshitting
they were they could get as big as 20 to
25 feet
they said they would look at pictures of
great white and they go that's nothing
man a guard was [ __ ] that size not as
fat but you know they would be like not
fat like that but longer you know more
dangerous yeah and i mean the thing
about it is that
you know
you can like i've seen eel and stuff
like that that were 20 feet long it's
not as impressive because they're not
like as big a round yeah they're not
massive but they're long
like a big old long 20 foot long
alligator without any without any arms i
could see that yeah i could see that
i've seen ones like i said i've been
snorkeling uh you know in central
central florida like ocala type area and
i've seen alligator guard that were
maybe
six feet seven feet something like that
like you know i've seen ones like that
so it doesn't
i think the limitation with the gar is
this
the gar also can't chew
it has a long snout and a lot of [ __ ]
razor sharp needle life like teeth it
can catch a fish but it swallows fish
whole now what yeah
it doesn't chew
so how long would it have to be
to swallow a human in a single swallow
that would have to be really big because
their mouths are
yeah kind of narrow it's got a sphincter
in it like a booty hole
behind the [ __ ] like a big old booty
hole so it goes he's getting off he's
got a mouse
yeah yeah it's
like it's going anal
so
so you have to compute how big
how big does a gar have to be to eat his
child
because i think that's what okay now
maybe okay that's what it was mostly
accused of from what i remember eating
eating the children that were swimming
okay now i can see that maybe it would
kill a child drown it maybe by drowning
it and then maybe eat it later they
can't they can't chew but they can't
swallow it whole
to swallow it whole how long would it be
it would have to be
well it wasn't just length it would have
to be girth yeah because
even little kids
have shoulders you know the length and
girth would be proportional though you'd
have to do the thing you have to talk to
experts
what's the biggest one and what was the
biggest thing it could swallow how big
how how big could
how big of a person could it swallow if
it made it to 20 25 feet maybe it could
swallow a six to seven year old child
you don't know well because the thing
about it is that you know we've seen
river monsters right and like some of
the
catfish in particular that jeremy wade
has caught
um
they could totally swallow a dude's head
okay like easily big enough for that
but
as far as shoulders get like as
impressive as some of these fish are
because like sometimes he pulls them up
and it's like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude i
don't feel like you know they're big but
i don't know if they could swallow a
whole person maybe they could like
swallow a head or they could swallow you
kind of feet first and then i don't know
kind of gum you in half i don't really i
don't really know but i kind of feel
like an alligator gar because they're
uh their head is so narrow
yeah i'm not really sure
i don't know they could i mean you could
just drown and they could be like hey
uh you know free canapes or whatever and
then like they save you for later like i
said like alligators do alligator
actually doesn't have to swallow you
whole yeah
they just drown your ass and then tuck
you away and then they'll just eat you
at their leisure graham says i've never
seen a guard bigger than a couple feet
you can go on youtube right now and go
look at videos
valigate big alligator guard in
mississippi and louisiana no they're
easy 10 feet 10
10 12 feet i mean i think the biggest
one i've ever seen was six feet but that
was like that was a few years ago yeah
and that's not several years ago that's
not no that's not a big one i'm just
saying that's the biggest one i've seen
but no you'll see it's easy to fight him
over 10 feet 10 feet around that but
here's the thing
i've talked about this on other shows
and jeremy wade talked about it on river
monsters
we don't know how long these things
live they don't ever seem to stop
growing they just continue to grow the
older they get
there's a lot of evidence that these
things can live
more than a hundred years
but those animals
didn't make it because in in the early
1900s block and tackle and people moving
into those areas
caught all those [ __ ] really huge
hundred and something year old fish
they're long gone
so this they never really replenished
because people were catching them at 5
10 15 years old because people are out
there fishing
something like an alligator guard maybe
how long does it
how how long does it get how big does it
get if it's 200 years old
don't know
it could be like loch ness monsters
right
seems to be that certain fish and
certain reptiles don't have a maximum
size
that they continue to grow their whole
life
until they're killed
or starved
they starve because they're not getting
enough food
well yeah once you get to a certain size
you need a certain caloric intake right
to maintain that size and if you don't
get that then you'll start to degenerate
sure and we're not we don't live in a
dinosaur age anymore where there's huge
[ __ ]
fish and animals running around
everywhere that era is gone
so should be some of these aquatic
animals
are limited in the amount in the size
that they could get they just can't get
that big they'll starve
but that may not have been the case long
time ago
example
we know about the megalodon [ __ ]
gigantic shark
who's to say that that's just not an
average old shark it's just ha maybe
that shark was 300 years old
because it could get that old because
there was a [ __ ] huge fish that they
could eat back then
so yeah it was just cruising right it
didn't even know what time it was did
you know it was 300 years old it didn't
give [ __ ] like whatever i'm just
swimming around [ __ ] i mean people have
commented who [ __ ] owned these things
and people have taken care of alligators
that 120 year old alligators is every
bit
as [ __ ] vibrant
and light and filled with life as a
newborn they don't get old and slow
they're exactly as they were
so they don't age like a human
yeah it's going on perpetual trt
you want another one of these drinks
yeah you know he wasn't going to be able
to
there's something about there's
something about their anabolic processes
let me get that oh they don't need that
it's empty yeah it's empty i'll throw it
away though
okay
i need a garbage can in here
yeah it's like i don't know i'm sure
they've done more research now i'd have
to like look more into it but i do kind
of feel like reptilians
i don't know if they actually know what
the outer limits of their like age range
is i mean i know that like you know
galapagos tortoises and stuff like that
they know that those have lived at least
100 years if not more
um so
you know like i said maybe it's kind of
a thing where
they're just very
relatively
simple it's like you know we're just
sleeping most of the time just hanging
out we're just walking around or
swimming around or whatever the case may
be
just eating [ __ ] and
you know they're not worrying about [ __ ]
maybe that's what we should all aspire
to i don't really know but yeah so i
don't know
i really do did i say that like last
time i was talking about because i took
a video when i was at the alligator farm
of the dude feeding all the alligators
and it's like hundreds of alligators
like coming in and like trying to climb
up the [ __ ] and i thought i said that i
was gonna like post it but i don't
remember if i ever did
i know i posted one that was like that
big ass [ __ ] crocodile
which scared the [ __ ] out of me
even though he's not nearly as big as
the one that they used to have gomek
that died a long time ago
but what the [ __ ] is going on with this
okay
um that one is like stuffed now
but they have one that's live named
maximo
and
he's pretty big it's pretty impressive
he's not as big as the other one he's
not as um
he's almost as long as gomek but he's
not as big around i think the thing that
impressed me about gomek because i saw
gomek when i was still
well hi pokey you going to be on the
show you coming she's coming up in the
chair
are you going to be my co-host
you want to be a co-host she's like i
don't give a [ __ ] about any of that
what's going on
let's go look at her face
what's going on
we're talking about alligators
yeah
have you ever seen an alligator pokey
she
but yeah so it was um almost as long as
gomec but i kind of feel like it wasn't
quite as impressive because gomek when
he was alive because i saw him when he
was alive was like way bigger around i
feel like he was like much bigger around
than
the new crocodile that they have but
like i said
what are they gonna do they need like a
big ass crocodile that everybody can
[ __ ] yeah you sleepy me too
look at her
yeah
you didn't even know you're on the show
do you poke
you don't even know you're on the show
uh yeah let's what are we talking about
donuts oh my god
okay
look at it
put pokey took your chair oh [ __ ] trying
to host the show that's what i said she
was being my co-host there for a second
even though she was kind of like that
and then she's like yeah [ __ ] it i'm
just gonna wash my face yeah
she doesn't know what's going on
[Laughter]
she likes that chair when you're not in
it
she comes in here sometimes and like
sleeps in it for hours at a time
like if i'm in here working which one
about time you wanna go she's trying to
tell me that she can't open it it's
daylight out though she doesn't think
she can open the door when the door shut
the door doesn't close though so it's
like i don't know why she doesn't like
stick her little paw under there and
open it yeah she doesn't know how to
open it well she wants you to do it yeah
she wants me to do it
it's much better for you to do things
than her and i have to do
esther's in there she's still being
pestered by somebody by troll
then maybe they eventually banned the
troll
yeah it looked like they've been uh
banned
esther says uh anyone like what we do in
the shadows
i've been meaning to like get into that
because that sounds like exactly up my
alley i just did i recorded a review of
um
do do do only lovers left alive
which is the jim jarmusch vampire movie
which is going up tomorrow or today if
you had if you're on patreon
um but
i kind of feel like it's this in the
same spirit
a little bit
but so i really need to get into that
what you doing
i'm um
messing with somebody all right well you
talk because i have to go to the
bathroom okay good
what you doing pokey you still just
sitting over here she's trying to get me
to entertain her
oh you're bored
yeah i'm uh this manual this uh radio
came with a huge ass manual all these
different functions and everything how
to turn the keyboard on how to lower the
power
how to use the vox settings it's taken
me days and i was actually an rto which
is uh well it was one of the jobs that i
had for a while as an rto when i was a
recon scout
i used the prc-170 prc-77 radio that one
in the cingars
i also used the um what was that the
thing the uh
the 163 which is the squad level radio
but we all just use them for local
communication pretty much squad level we
also use the scramblers
but uh all that shit's obsolete and i
was looking i was looking at some little
equipment wheels that we used to use we
didn't know the specs we just knew how
to run them
and i was looking at the specs and it
goes god damn that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
there's not much there they weren't very
powerful they were only like one way one
one watt radios
i guess they were trying to keep
most of
radio silence down to a minimum because
it was all such a local communications
they just gave you just one watt this
this sucker here they claim 10
but it's probably closer to eight
what oh
sorry cheat back
gramps isn't most southern fruit fried i
lived in north carolina
use enough canola canola oil to float a
battleship um yeah a lot of southern
food surprise although i kind of feel
like that's that's more like an old
school thing it's stereotype but a lot
of it is friday yeah yeah
i mean nowadays you can kind of you can
get anything you want down here yeah
southern food is now
relegated to an ethnic food
we're in we're in uh
florida
and to get real southern food you have
to go to a soul food restaurant as
if
southern food is soul food and soul food
soul food is southern food and sun food
is soul food but it it's just southern
food
but they have it kind of in a damn
ethnic category
you know like only black people eat that
no white people eat that too
that would that was so um
you know that cracker barrel is still a
thing right yeah and bob evans i think
is still around yeah i guess that's kind
of southern that's southern but that's
not that's not what you would have it's
say like a local southern diner
in a small town it wouldn't it would be
closer to what you got to shop and i
mean there's still like a lot of
i mean you know we live
right outside of orlando so right you're
gonna be able to get pretty much
anything you want to get that you could
get anywhere else
but if let's say if i was gonna visit my
dad back in heidelberg mississippi now
we're gonna ride up to the [ __ ]
main road the closest restaurant would
be jr's [ __ ] truck stop
all right which is like right there on
[ __ ] what is that hi
i4 i-75 i think it's i-75 i think but it
goes all the way to michigan
and uh
here the the food you're gonna get there
is very much kind of like you get
chantals and they would call that soul
food but not not mississippi it would
just be food
[Laughter]
which is you know
greens
fried okra
grits for breakfast you know different
kinds of grits
a lot of bacon
um
you know breakfast food is pretty much
the same everywhere in the united states
except you know [ __ ] the southern
versus going to have grits in there too
oh yeah now i want some grit yeah it's
good uh but you can have you know fried
stuffed fried okra fried chicken
um we just got fried chicken
which is banana pudding with [ __ ]
nilla wafers in it all the [ __ ]
whipped cream on top i don't like it i
don't like i don't like bananas in it
i'm not a banana fan sweet potato pie
okay that's good um
pumpkin pie they have it but they just
look at it sideways they're like wide
net sweet potato
honestly i like
i know it's very basic [ __ ] but i will
like pumpkin spice all the things yeah
pumpkin spice cheerios pumpkin spice
pork loin
all the [ __ ]
that's good that pumpkin spices is in
sweet potato pie too yeah too it's it's
mostly it tastes pretty much the same to
me it tastes real close
i mean i can't really if you gave me a
blind taste test i'm not really sure i
could taste the difference pumpkin a
[ __ ] pecan pie all year round
i love pecan pie it's super super sweet
though yeah it's all year round heated
with [ __ ] scoop of vanilla ice cream
on it and that's just you can get that
all year round because i love pokemon
cobbler
which is like a different kind of
[ __ ] cherry cobbler apple cobbler
berry cobbler dj maniacs cobbler that's
the [ __ ] big ones peach cobbler
although i'm more into like cherry and
apples i like honest i'm not a huge fan
like i'll eat peach but it's not my
favorite peach comes out of the can
yeah it comes out of the can and it's
common you're gonna have that i know you
know what i mean yeah i had it grown up
yeah i grew up i grew up here that's the
main one
he's from california and he like tells
me it's like yeah i know i'm from both i
i grew up here i grew up here too i grew
up mississippi too and my grandma and my
grandma's from tennessee yeah so she
made all the southern [ __ ] right uh dj
maniac says bob evans and cracker barrel
only show up in supermarkets here we
consider them a brand not a restaurant
lol yeah it's kind of like we still have
cracker bread i don't know is bob evans
still around
i don't know if it still is i remember
there was one in daytona i don't know if
there's any here still i kind of i know
evans over there right there [ __ ] at
this intersection remember is there
they're red right red white trim yeah
it's over there in memories of india
across the street from it
oh okay
yeah it's about i didn't remember we
don't ever like there you go they're
pretty famous for their biscuits and
gravy i think i've only been there once
in my whole entire life they do not
allow anyone in there under the age of
60.
okay you're under the age of 60. you
can't go
[Laughter]
yeah the only way you can go in there is
if you have like [ __ ] you got a year
you gotta have the senior discount yeah
that's an old person's restaurant do you
got tuna melts dairy queens yeah hop yes
yeah all of that
tuna melts you know who used to have
decent tuna melts friendlies yeah i
don't know if they're still around
though they were mostly known as an ice
cream place but they had like sandwiches
and stuff too they had a pretty decent
tuna mento cheese sandwich okay and then
there's a pimento cheese milk
if you guys haven't seen that that's
[ __ ] shredded
cheddar cheese we just we ate it in ihop
let me finish not too long after why let
me finish i can explain
[Laughter]
shredded cheddar cheese with mayonnaise
and pimentos in it
okay
let it secure
just stir it up let it cure for a few
hours spread that on [ __ ] toast
butter each side and fry it
on the other side turn it into like a
pimento cheese melt man it's just good
don't let it melt all the way through
it'll just turn into crap yeah i mean
you still want the [ __ ] cheese
filling to kind of be a little cool
that's good another one is
what was that
it was mayonnaise
and
um
cream cheese
with black olives in it remember that
you make that down
black olives black olive [ __ ] black
actually [ __ ] olives in general but [ __ ]
black olives
i think it might have had some
green onion in it too
it's been a long time since i've made it
that was really good
cream cheese spread
it's good with crackers and it's good on
bread
toast
why is you gotta put [ __ ] black
olives on
they're like they're like the raisins
you have red
that's like putting raisins and [ __ ] why
would you do that
like oh i have these delicious oatmeal
cookies let's put raisins in them yeah
no black olives are great let's not do
that because you have black olives in a
southern cupboard it's just in there
like i'll eat them but i'm not happy
about it because a lot of times like
sometimes for whatever reason
tom [ __ ] loves black olives i love
him yeah so we always have we have the
ridiculous like [ __ ] five gallon can
of black olives like from sam's or
whatever so it's like whenever he makes
pizza ask her if she wants something i
always forget and he always every single
time how long have we been how long have
we noticed 11 years it's inconceivable
that do you want black olives on your
half [ __ ] no i don't it's inconceivable
that you can't put black olives on the
deck and then every now and then he'll
forget and put them on there anyway then
i got to pick them off i mean i'll eat
them i don't hate them i like them both
but green or black
shit's good i mean i can eat green
olives but again i'm not a fan i would
just rather not it's it a lot of food
i'm not gonna say oh my god i'm not
gonna eat that ever but i would just
rather not like if if you ask me do i
want that
put on there or not put on there i would
rather it not if it's on there i'll eat
it i'm not gonna be like a dick about it
but
i would rather it not be on there i
would rather my pizza and not have black
olives on it i'm just saying
i'll eat it with black olives on it if i
have to but i would rather not
um yeah tuna melts every now and then
like tommy tuna melt he usually just
makes like a regular patty melt
because we don't usually have tuna
because i always forget to get it even
though i love tuna
but every now and then we'll have some
tuna and he'll make tuna melt um but
yeah i was gonna say other night from
the bar
we were coming back from mannequins
right
and we were like starving we hadn't
eaten like for
12 hours or something and we were kind
of drunk and we were like man let's go
to mcdonald's and mcdonald's was [ __ ]
closed for whatever reason even though
it's supposed to be open uh 24 hours and
we're like [ __ ] and we're like oh wait
there's an ihop
like on the other side like you have to
go
you know it's out of the way but it's
not that far so we kind of went around
to the ihop and i'm like man this is
like pretty nice in there so we got like
the whole like full breakfast thing but
the thing about it is that they give you
so much food
that i couldn't eat at all i'm gonna
have to uh put danny rose face in
timeout what did he do
i might have accidentally deleted it
don't worry about it what do you do
cause he said that people that put
[ __ ] [ __ ] like pineapple on pizza are
[ __ ] diluted and they [ __ ] up in
the head i [ __ ] had it i had to get
rid of that one it's not okay no [ __ ]
crazy daddy i know you're crazy ham and
pineapple pizza i know this is a very
divisive issue it is some it is a it is
a certain
it is a certain flavor unto itself
it's not like other kinds of pizzas
that's true
it
that's nothing you think that's in the
bottom some of you some people were like
well that's an abomination well i guess
you haven't been to cc's
or you haven't mentioned these or you
haven't been to the uk where they're
putting like
corn kernels on there yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah you have no idea what
you're talking about because they're
putting down they go to cece's they'll
take a [ __ ] pizza crust and they'll
put [ __ ] blueberry pie filling on it
and sprinkle a bunch of brown sugar on
that
dessert some coffee creamer and [ __ ]
bake that [ __ ] and then try to tell you
that that's a dessert pizza not gonna
let us know that was probably the [ __ ]
i feel like that's not a [ __ ] not so
much blueberry i'm not a huge fan i like
blueberry muffins and stuff but again
it's kind of like if you gave me all
right let's let's have a hypothetical
it's breakfast time you give me an array
of muffins let's say that
here's a cinnamon one here's one with
strawberries in here there's one
blueberries in it blueberry is never
gonna be my first choice they're good
uh if you're making blueberry muffins
and you ask me do i want one sure
um but if you're making a bunch of
different ones with different stuff in
them i will choose pretty much
everything before i will choose a
blueberry just saying
let's
read what david june said wait where is
it because well because i was saying up
here that um
yeah him pineapple well okay i i will
say i know that's very divisive
especially on the internet people are
just like oh my god like people that put
pineapple on their pizza are like
[ __ ] degenerates or whatever
it's not my favorite like it's never
it's not my first pick of pineapple
toppings
but again
if you're like hey you want a hawaiian
pizza with like some pineapple on it
yeah i'll eat that
it's good it's not my favorite but it's
it's still good so i'm not so i don't
like i don't have strong feelings about
it one way either tom is going mad with
power yes it almost feels like he was
replaced with an evil clone yes um i'm
i'm banning people now he's always been
mad with power i don't know why uh you
just know that nowadays always mad at
power
um
i can't believe that you blocked danny
rowling for saying that he didn't like
the pineapple i know you said no he said
the people that liked pineapple on pizza
were [ __ ] in the head and then oh you
gotta go
because i [ __ ] love it i don't mind
being [ __ ] in the head like i said
it's not my favorite [ __ ] love it
but if you offer it to me it's one of my
favorites i'll eat it i like all because
it's still pretty good i make all kinds
of [ __ ] pizza i like really good
pizzas and one of the ones
is having pineapple but it's it's own
thing
i know it's not like
you got to be in the mood for you got to
be in the mood for it and you have to
know how to do that pineapple the right
it can't be a really big piece of
pineapple it's not going to cook
properly
so if it comes out of the can and it's
too thick you got to slice the those
pieces of pineapple a little bit thinner
so they'll kind of heat up a little bit
and kind of cook
um
and you got to have the right kind of
ham for it too you know if you could get
black forest ham
or canadian bacon you're [ __ ] that
that's really good because see it has to
be a pretty salty piece of ham
well yeah because you want sweet sweet
sweet and salty that's kind of the whole
like
point of the enterprise sure that's the
whole thing and if you don't like that
combo then i can understand not liking
my hand i'm not hating i'm not
be honest that's not good on things like
deep dish or pan pizza
no it doesn't work you don't work the
same yeah you want a thin pizza or a
hand tossed pizza
oh what they would call hands i was like
medium you just don't want thin curl you
don't want thick crust or pan with ham
and pineapple it's not good it's going
to be honest can i have i ever seen like
a deep dish pizza with ham and pineapple
yeah i'm sure i'm sure they make it but
they'll they'll they'll make it it's not
really the same experience it's not the
same it's not the same
it has to be where you can eat many
slices and not get full there's just
something about it
you want it pizza is weird that way yeah
you want to be able to eat a whole large
pizza
and you're still not [ __ ] overstuffed
you want it to be kind of thin there's
something about the toppings well i have
to say and i was thinking about this the
other day
pizza
has kind of like this weird magical
quality yeah where
even somebody like me who seriously i
can't even eat a whole like ihop
breakfast without
throwing up it's like too much food like
with the eggs and the bacon and the
pancakes i couldn't eat it all and even
after that like i couldn't eat it all
and then i threw up anyway
but
even me
i can eat probably whole pizza by myself
and just be like yep
i don't understand how that happens
because that's like because it's cheese
and bread
and it's like you'd think that
somebody like me that eats
you know a little bit too much and i'm
just like oh man i'm gonna barf but i
could probably eat a whole piece by
myself no problem all right i'm gonna
[ __ ] lay some [ __ ] out for you people
you're gonna lay some [ __ ] out some [ __ ]
out [ __ ] t's gonna love this this is
a california story
like i said you know what i mean
i was actually born in california but i
spent every summer of my life in
mississippi up until i was sucking until
i left from brazil like in 81 or 82.
um but the rest of the time i was in the
long beach area in long beach california
and go down to san diego and stuff
somewhere around long beach i remember
where it was there was a restaurant that
i used to [ __ ] love it i used to
[ __ ] love this restaurant my mom used
to take me every now and then it was
kind of a treat to go maybe once a year
i'd get to go maybe twice a year
and it was a pollen it was that it was a
tiki restaurant it was a polynesian
restaurant called kalbos yeah you can
look it up on the internet it's gone now
and it was a [ __ ]
it looked like a [ __ ] it looked like
something out of damn disneyland it
looked like a lighthouse and around it
was a bunch of [ __ ] tropical bushes
like you're going into the jungle and
you went in there and it was all this
undersea motif they had like
fake divers and it was dark as [ __ ] in
there and then they had a damn
glass window with a bunch of [ __ ] in the
glass like macaroni and a [ __ ]
smooshed
jelly peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
and [ __ ] beads and [ __ ] and you had
to wait what there was the peanut butter
and jelly sandwich like in the garbage
stained glass window and then it had it
yeah it was all preserved it was all
that loose site [ __ ] and [ __ ] you know
like i get that but that's still little
and it had lights shining through the
back of it and it felt like you were
like at disneyland in the [ __ ]
undersea ride what was that twenty
thousand leagues on the sea yeah it was
like that
then they had stuffed fish and blowfish
and [ __ ] hanging from the ceiling and it
was sucking dark in there and had a bar
and then had all these little booths it
was all this bamboo and they had [ __ ]
uh weird polynesian hawaiian music it
was all popular back in the 50s and it
was [ __ ] it was neat and then on the
side of each
booth
was a
a lit up
a lit up menu and it was mostly the
drink menu i think it was lit up there
was serve it all down flaming fumbles
and
[ __ ] skull and bones drinks and
[ __ ] weird every drink was like a
damn
[ __ ] theme drink it's a whole
production the whole [ __ ] production
and then they had uh
a menu all right and the menu is really
good
and there's a couple things i used to
get that was there one first thing was
[ __ ] egg rolls
and i've never had an egg roll like this
ever since it the egg roll
was two long egg rolls and did it have
spam in it tom no
there's two long egg rolls that were cut
you know i'm talking about sliced so you
could pick them up and you could dip
them
in this [ __ ] delicious [ __ ] sauce
and looking back on it it was kind of
like a cross between
today what you would call that um
thai sweet chili sauce probably mixed
with [ __ ]
soy
but it was something homemade
wasn't something that they bought
but then they had these um
barbecue pork
sandwiches that you couldn't pick up and
eat
it was an open fake sandwich well yeah
you gotta like and you would pour
and it had slices of pineapple on it see
yeah so that whole ham and pineapple
[ __ ] aspect of those pizzas kind of
reminds me of this these of kalbo's
it was a big open face sandwich it had
like sesame seed buns
it had fries but i think the fries were
[ __ ] sweet potato or yams
i think i don't think they were i don't
think they were very ahead of its time
yeah i don't think they were i don't
think they were
potato it's been a long time but i think
it was sweet potato mmm potato fries
yeah and
each sandwich came with a ladle and in
the ladle it had a secret sauce and i've
never been able
to replicate that kalbo's
barbecue sauce
and
the family that owned it won't release
it they said it was a family recipe and
they they and now they're all done
they're gone now you know and the
[ __ ]
no one will ever know
people have left
messages on like a cowboys appreciation
[ __ ] sites on the internet you know
like when they asked about what was
how'd they make that sauce and a family
never chimed in this is it's a family
recipe we'll never give up the [ __ ] of
that sauce
and it was
barbecue sauce
when i think pineapple juice
brown sugar
and something else it was either i mean
someone's got to hit upon that [ __ ]
at some point right i mean there's only
so many ingredients you can put soy
sauce in it too
and the the rumor had a secret
ingredient and a rumor was that came
from somebody that worked there it was
[ __ ] bourbon it was jim beam i think
or jack daniels or something was in it
it was [ __ ] beautiful
you could pour that over a pork sandwich
and this [ __ ] was just oh it came with a
big old [ __ ] pickle i remember that
too like a garlic pickle ooh sliced
garlic pig it's called kel bows now i
want a deep fried pickle yeah
last time i had a deep fried pickle i
was at hamburger mary's oh that's like
one of their like uh
i don't know if appetizers if t [ __ ]
knows anything about cowboys that was
that was back in the back
she goes look up look up traders she's
telling me to look up trader vic's i
don't know that one the mai tai
yeah
it's funny like
it's a tiki spot called trader vic's
located in you know what's weird last
time i was in new york city which is
probably back in like 2008 or 2009
i don't know if any of you you guys from
the nyc area know what i'm talking about
but there was a really cool
tiki bar
it wasn't too far off where was i
staying i feel like i was staying on
maybe 34th street so i feel like it was
maybe not too far from there because i
know i walked and it wasn't all that far
but there was a bar that was like a tiki
type bar and it was like super cool they
played like a lot of
that's trader vic's
okay that place is looks really open and
nice compared to cowboys all right
kilboz was like that but imagine if they
were going to shoot a porn film in a
situation like that i'm going to show
you maybe it looked like they
do porn there in a minute let me see if
i can find seattle i'm a big fan of
restaurants
that are like that that are dark
i don't like these big brightly lit
everybody is like there's no booths
everybody's just sitting out like
looking at one another and the braille i
don't like that there is the front of
the cowboys menu yeah
hawaiian barbecue yeah let me see if i
can find pictures again
there's the front of kelbos
yeah
that's the one you went to uh yeah it
didn't look like that when i went there
though
when i went there it had more trees
around it
just
maybe it was like maybe it did look like
that do you remember like a while back
we went to like the red lobster that was
around here
and i was super happy to see that they
hadn't
uh quote unquote modernized and made it
all open and like bright and stuff
because i don't like that i remembered
that sign
that's a great scent look look he's all
sad
yeah
and dancing was anybody dancing when
you're not i was there i'm trying to see
if i can find it okay man you [ __ ] the
lighting all up look what you did there
is an interior shot
in black and white
of the bar
who's that guy doing now i don't know
see if i can fix it for a second i
thought it was roger corman but it's not
okay wait a minute
okay
okay that's not the same one hold on one
second
all right
all right
there's the that's what it looked like
when you first walked in
focus [ __ ]
you can't force it you just gotta relax
okay
that was a fountain that's near where
that [ __ ] peanut butter and jelly
sandwich was so it's a little bit like
when you walked into like the rainforest
cafe
you know what i mean yeah
at downtown disney that's what the
rainforest cafe used to look like at the
beginning at the entrance
which i only ate in one time what is
kind of fun but
you know
that's the thing you just you eat there
because it's like cool and it's the
ambiance but the foods
i mean the food's not terrible but it's
just like it's not that memorable either
okay
this is what kilboz looked like on the
inside so it was dark
see i'm into dark restaurants i like
dark restaurants and this isn't this
they got a light on so you can see it
but when you walked down through there
it was dark like it was nighttime like
you were in [ __ ] yeah see and it had
an artificial ceiling that looked like
it had stars and [ __ ] so it was like you
were walking in between
huts and those things on the right
are booths and each booth is inside like
a little hut like you went into your own
little hut
and they got all the damn tiki statues
everywhere
and then hanging from the ceiling were
like
fish
dried up
plasticated sea fish like marlin and
[ __ ]
spike fish and you know there's blowfish
and stuff
let's see if i can fly see like i said
i'm not a real big fan of
you know i know there's been like a big
trend of like oh let's make this big
open area and it's all brightly lit
and it's all like white and i don't
those were the lit up
drink menu on the side of each one of
the tables look at that yeah fantastic
i'm not a big fan
on the side of each table they had that
menu
lit up
and you'd i'd sit there as a little kid
and look at that thing there'd be a
light behind it
with all these damn pretty
pictures see i would still be all about
that even nowadays even though i'm
clearly not a kid anymore yeah
i don't get this whole
hey i'm gonna sit in like a big open
room that's all brightly lit with a
bunch of [ __ ] i don't know
and eat some food i don't like that
i want to like sit in a booth by myself
where i don't have to see anybody else
and eat my food in [ __ ] peace
yeah you know what i'm saying i don't i
don't like this whole
i don't like that whole open concept i
don't like it
[Laughter]
i'm just saying i i know that's like
kind of
that's that's kind of like the trend
nowadays i guess it's like we're in this
big open room and everything's like
brightly lit i don't like it
i don't like it
i want my own i want my own booth i want
to pretend like i'm at home but not at
home i don't have to clean up afterwards
that's the way that men you'd looked and
that was thank you tom ross's evil clone
boobs it would it would [ __ ]
it would stagger me as a kid is that
there's a little naked polynesian woman
there and he's even back then tom was
like ooh boobies he's like look at this
man he's putting the crab in her crab is
going to bite her in the ass wait he's
putting a crab up her butt yeah she's
trying to get her dress she's trying to
grab her dress and he's [ __ ] putting
the crap look i'm just minding my own
business trying to put my clothes back
on and you're sticking a crab up my ass
and then the dudes in the boat are
cheering it on they're like that's right
bite that [ __ ] in the ass you see this
is the this is this is the world i came
from see typically that was that typical
acceptable behavior
that was all it that's the way it should
be isn't it that's what it should be
because no one cares about girls or what
they want or what they want to do it's
all just funny it's all just it's all
well it's all funny to you because
you're not in there's the go-go's there
isn't it the go-go's there that is the
ghost that is the go-go's
right there yeah and then there's the
go-go's at kilboz
there's belinda carlyle yeah
i see it yeah i see it
but like i said i kind of feel like a
lot of that was predicated on and i'm
not saying because that's like a cool
aesthetic and everything but it's a lot
of that's predicated on
hey let's
let's stick a crab up a girl's ass so
you don't really care about what the
girl is doing
no that's might you be your girlfriend
just
look at him drinking there's the go-go's
drinking the flame in a fun bowl of
cowboys see people knew what was cool
with it
i like how they're all leaner of the
table looking at like look at how big
that [ __ ] is
look how big that [ __ ] is i mean [ __ ]
oh my god
[ __ ] got to have a sense of humor
we're talking about
[Laughter]
oh my god
why but like i said
yes [ __ ]
so
yeah you [ __ ] up my lighting look at
what you did i do it out oh yeah what
happened
you did that
because you kept holding [ __ ] up to the
camera and the camera got confused
so now i'm just telling the truth now
ugh yeah no it's a little bright no one
wants that
yeah tiki bars need hula dancers though
i think they have them sometimes
yeah they probably had like a special
that's some like special occasions back
in the day that we went there you know
it been during the weekday during the
slow nights
places like that back in the days in the
70s were [ __ ] packed in the early 80s
they were packed all the time well like
i said back in the 70s and early 80s
nobody had netflix right you had to go
out all the time nobody had big giant
tvs right in their house
you couldn't really entertain yourselves
at home
no you know
you had to go out and do things yeah
they were actually like going to dinner
was like a form of entertainment
but it's just not anymore yeah i mean
even when i was a kid it kind of was
because i kind of feel like friday night
saturday night
you know like i said i grew up in
daytona beach so you drive by [ __ ]
hooters man that place would be [ __ ]
hopping
friday saturday night
everybody be there getting the wings
watching the game the the sports ball
game it does look washed out didn't it
yeah but it didn't look like that before
but you did that because you kept
holding light colored stuff up to the
camera
that's some weird [ __ ]
how does it do that
because it hates you i don't know no i'm
just saying because it knows
you know it actually looks okay i'm on
it doesn't look nice washed out it
doesn't look quite as washed out
i mean for the ones we record i usually
like darken it
just so we don't get like too much
light in here yeah uh camp guy said
there was a moroccan restaurant atlanta
where you took off your shoes and sat on
pillows
and it had belly dancers yeah
they're everybody's timing each other
out that's right time to fix that if
people are acting bad time them out
did we even do we start that trend now
where everyone's just gonna like people
people haven't started acting bad until
recently
yeah well it all started
when the message was deleted like by
tila he gave me two dollars and then
they tila deleted the message she'd
probably [ __ ] say i don't know what
he's saying
talking crazy well it was just kind of
like when when all the trolls started
appearing yeah which like i said is
annoying but in some ways i was telling
before we started recording i was kind
of like
well at least that means that like we're
attracting attention now
so
yeah
you know i don't care that shit's all
fun and games to be out really
we've been having people we didn't get
hit by a [ __ ] bot troll we had we had
a couple of them come in here that could
post
long sentences just one right after like
that troll had that [ __ ] [ __ ] lined
up
and it was all racist eddie semetic [ __ ]
with [ __ ] swastikas and all kinds of
[ __ ] well that was like earlier like
somebody else somebody was no somebody
was doing that earlier oh where are they
okay
they're like one of their names was
something something hitler was right and
i'm just like really is that the best
you can come up with good job but you
know what i mean i'm sure i'm sure it's
not a person that's a computer doing it
yeah
it's never what it appears to be
just doing that [ __ ]
if it's a person it's a really lame
person yeah it's almost it's usually a
computer
it's a computer from a from a competitor
from a competing site that's trying to
jam a site or get somebody that if okay
for instance
youtube has pretty good security that it
can detect when a computer is trying to
do [ __ ] like that in the live streams
and it'll shut it off
but if you look at say like bit shoot
[ __ ] [ __ ] has very little defenses
you'll see all kinds of
[ __ ] nothing but just racial slurs
all in the comment sections
but you can tell they're not really
they don't interact with anybody that
that talks to them well it's not super
coherent it's not real coherent yeah so
it's what it is is it's some some
company somewhere has this [ __ ] bot
that's doing that to try to drive people
off that platform and maybe like
probably get them to youtube it might be
youtube doing that or youtube hiring
companies to do that to competitors
although honestly
most of what i get i don't get like
after the fact like every now and then
we get like this stupid thank you no
need for me to
wife made it through surgery okay yeah i
was gonna ask about that because uh yeah
she was having surgery she's asleep doc
says she should be able to come home
tomorrow not trying to kill the vibe
just happy well that's good though but
thank you very much yeah but like i said
when we get
trolls in the live chat
it's almost always nazi stuff yeah um
when i get trolls on comments on the
videos it's almost always uh sex bots
yeah like hey come to my site
look i'm so foxy that's usually the [ __ ]
i have to delete it's not super
egregious it's usually facebook is
usually that
yeah i get weird messages through
facebook about come join me at my [ __ ]
and this and that and [ __ ] come and
what it is it's always worded the same
way
so you know what i mean like justin has
changed and the photographs have changed
the ones on youtube i usually only get
like one or two a day maybe and it's
usually like a comment on an older video
or whatever and it's usually like hey
follow me here and it's like some hot
chick on the whatever yeah yeah and then
it's all like emojis emojis and see my
videos like lips yeah yeah yeah yeah
hearts and whatever yeah yeah
and the english is wonky
either a.i wrote it or a foreigner wrote
it
although
i've heard
that the ai is so good now that it can
write and interact to a certain extent
with people
on all these platforms in the comments
section
but you might only get through like a
couple of interactions before it starts
saying things that people don't say
yeah i kind of feel like
i don't know man i don't i don't know if
anybody's passed the turing test yet
have they no no where it's kind of like
after
a certain amount of interaction you're
like yeah this isn't a person you're
right
has anybody like been able to like get
past that no
i kind of feel like no
no i can i can kind of spot something in
two
in in two interactions that sounds not
right
yeah and like i said most of the [ __ ]
like i said in the live stream
it tends to be
it's one person or it's one bot that
keeps changing their
name and it's usually something
nazi related not too related yeah um and
you know like something i think the one
we got earlier was like hitler was right
there was something like so so-so is a
jew or something like that yeah um so
you always get kind of some [ __ ] like
that
and
but the [ __ ] that they post doesn't
really make a lot of sense and they can
interact with somebody or call somebody
in the damn chat room too
which is weird it's the ai's doing that
i think it's difficult to say difficult
to say it doesn't
it never felt real to me
but like i said i mean honestly
if it's real it's a child
but i don't but even a child is more
innovative
i don't think it's real i think it's a
computer program that does and one way
or the other whether it's a person or
whether it's a computer honestly i don't
really care either way yeah uh you're
just being a douche and i'm not going to
pay attention to you because that's
clearly what you want if you are a
person
or if you're a computer we're paying
attention right now because we're
talking about it well no i'm just saying
that in general i always just want to
know if it's a person i don't think they
cares if it's a person i don't think
they are people because they don't
interact deeply enough
and honestly never seen them interact if
it's a person
don't give them any attention because
that's what they want and if it's a
computer also don't give them any
attention so computer
i think it's just a box i kind of react
to them the same way that i react to sex
bots that put
uh you know comments on every new video
that i put up you just delete it
just delete it don't interact don't do
anything that's what they want
david's trolling on a second account
y'all that's what tila said
he's being a booty
okay and honestly like i said i do not
like i mean of all the things that i do
yeah but i was still donating okay of
all the things i don't like and that's a
long list
of all the things i don't like
attention [ __ ]
is real near the top of that list so
you're trying to get attention whether
you're a person or you're a computer
then i will take great delight in
denying you that attention yeah i'm just
saying
did pokey open the door again yeah she
[ __ ] threw herself against the damn
door
y'all could sort that out between you
between yourselves in there in the
comments section
um
david um just chill the [ __ ] out i guess
don't uh don't be
picking on people
where are you at pookie
the knee for me too says just walking
away isn't an option people take much
anymore which i don't understand because
it's like honestly i have
40 million better things to do
than spend my time
dealing with
other people's stupidity
so
and i'm old
look like i'm almost 50. so i'm kind of
like i've got to a point now it's like
look if you're just gonna like say
stupid [ __ ]
you're gonna get deleted no one's gonna
care about you anymore just please die
alone
um no one cares about it's not like you
feel any hatred or anger just die
[ __ ]
i'm not it's not hatred or anger it's
just it's it's contempt and indifference
i think a lot of it is not honestly it's
contempt and different i think a lot of
it is not people and honestly
if it's people or if it's not people
um it doesn't matter to me one way or
the other um
the end result is the same yeah so
contempt and indifference that's all i
kind of feel toward those type of people
if that's all that you have to do with
your time
uh that's kind of sad but i'm not
you know
you know it's not my job to like educate
you or make your life better or anything
like that it's like you she's more
wallowing that [ __ ] then
that that's on you um i don't have any
responsibility i don't know what's up
i'm not really paying attention thank
you tom ross's evil clown boobs all
right let's get hey i'm chill i don't
think i'm trolling too much just being
dumb
dang
[Laughter]
yeah well maybe we made too many people
moderators
stop it pokey
side quest here lol she said die alone i
did
honestly
pookie
some people i think they should
some people i think they should i'm
gonna um
get another drink all right well let's
try to get on something a little more
upbeat jenny stop uh
let me take you down that path
if trolls give money
are they treated differently than the
non-paying trolls
i have never seen
trolls give money
but
i don't know i don't think i would treat
them any differently it's not like
they're giving me a million dollars or
anything like i can't retire on the [ __ ]
so you know
seriously okay camp guy
you are the third or fourth person that
has suggested to me brand new cherry
flavor
we are seriously going to watch that
last night
i don't know why i think tom got mad at
me
because he always he has this thing
where it's like i come in the room and
it's like look i've been working all day
and it's like
man i'm gonna like just [ __ ] watch
whatever
and i was like flipping through netflix
and i was like ooh true crime and he's
just like oh [ __ ] this and he goes and
plays a video game because he doesn't
want to like watch your crime
i
watched there's a series on netflix it's
only like three episodes i think but
it's called sophie
and it was called like a murder in west
cork
um which is actually very good i like
really got into it i kind of feel like
just go ahead there you go
i'm just talking you're like [ __ ] to my
face you see
i fixed it
i fixed that [ __ ] i saw the [ __ ]
thing change good job dark good job you
let me handle this
thank you thank you i appreciate that
but yeah so i was watching that last
night and it's like
but
i am gonna watch brand new cherry flavor
because like i said camp guy you were
like the fourth person we decided on the
channel name because uh that was the
time in which uh they had to [ __ ]
bring the damn baby back on [ __ ]
labyrinth
she
sarah had to get the goddamn baby back
by 13 o'clock no but haunted mansion
that too disney world haunted mansion
they have it all that's how
yeah i remember pretty distinctly when
we came up with the name for the channel
ah i had to do the labyrinth
no it wasn't that was a later that was
in your mind
in my mind it was the damn it was damn
david bowie
from the labyrinth
he goes at 13 o'clock you must have the
ba remember that you have to until 13
o'clock to get the baby
that's that's what i thought you're
talking about
yeah
that's what i was thinking
this is some revisionist history no it's
not right here no it's not it is because
i told you
the clock in the haunted mansion yeah at
disney world and disneyland yeah
um it has a thing where you go through
you're in the coffin
and you see like the grandfather
and it goes ding like that and it's 13
o'clock and i said oh that'd be a good
name for a channel
and i think that you are
and i said that's why we should name it
that cause the haunted mansion
and then later
yeah when we watched we we re-watched
labyrinth and i was like oh yeah they
had a 13 o'clock in that too i didn't
even remember
that labyrinth had that whole [ __ ]
that's the way i remember i remembered
it because of the haunted mansion okay
um and i was the one that came up with
the name
and you didn't say the [ __ ] about
labyrinth until later when we re-watched
the movie
how you turn my world you precious so
stop pretending
i know i love them
he tends to remember things he doesn't
remember things so good yeah right
[Laughter]
i remember stuff remember stuff real
well there's certain
yeah you remember certain things kind of
well it depends on what it is yeah it
depends on what it is what it is and
honestly when we came up with this name
i thought that we thought of it because
of the haunted mansion
maybe at disney world maybe later
later we saw it on [ __ ] and then
later
we re-watched labyrinth and i said oh i
forgot it's not that important there's
also no i'm just saying that it's like
well yeah that's why but i'm just saying
i remember
yeah i remember thinking about because i
totally forgot that there was a whole 13
o'clock thing in [ __ ] labyrinth i
forgot because i had a whole lot the
whole idea is that the show
exists in a time zone
that does not exist
well that was kind of well that's why i
liked that name because and that's why i
liked because one i'm a big fan of like
the haunted man i am the ghost of
troubled joe
hung by his pretty neck
pretty white that's right that's right
yeah from his pretty wide neck some 18
months ago i traveled to a mystical time
zone
then i missed my bed and i soon came
home go ahead too much caffeine in your
blood too much caffeine in my blood so
i know that's something
but no i'm just saying that it's like
the whole the whole thing of us coming
and i remember the night that we came up
with the name
[Music]
well yeah because like everything it
looks like a big [ __ ] joke to you
it's not true you don't take everything
and it's not seriously you can't i
seriously remember
we came up with the name because i said
oh remember
in haunted mansion yeah
at disney
uh they had the clock in there that goes
around and it's like 13 o'clock that's
so like that's really cool right and
it's like i said we could like
um you know it's like oh it's the hour
where that doesn't exist and it's like
this whole thing that doesn't happen and
it's like that would be like a really
cool name
and then i did a search on it the next
day
and saw that nothing else was called
that so i was kind of like okay well
that's what we're gonna call it
and then later on
we
re-watched
labyrinth which i had seen a million
times in the 80s but i hadn't seen for
many years oh [ __ ]
well i'm getting classy
are you
do you need a budweiser getting classy
as [ __ ] or schlitz
[Laughter]
you didn't carry like so sloppy right
now
it's all good
it's all good little dog
is it
your shit's crooked
let me handle this
you know where the back is right it's
it's where the little clamp is
there you go
i'm about ready to train me a tiger
train me a big one you guys last night
after i watched
the uh
the creepy like true crime series
he's like why would like put some mst on
or something
so i watched
space mutiny which is probably my
favorite
mystery science theater episode of all
time
that movie
it was made in like south africa right
they had all
red brown who was a bodybuilder
and he was in a bunch of other movies as
well
he was in that [ __ ]
uh there was some kind of sort of famous
people in it
uh the dude that was in barbarella that
played pygar what was that dude's name
he was in it
um
cameron mitchell who i feel like was in
a lot of b-movies he was in it
uh and
man they tried so hard
they tried so hard to make this a good
sci-fi movie and it was just really
really not
but in a delightful way i love
all the chases
with what are essentially golf carts
yeah they're pretending like they're
going fast it's [ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
and like
i love that they made so many jokes
about them being like zamboni's and
stuff because that's pretty much exactly
what they look like
i can't i can't go that fast i have to
drop the waxing compound
it's like it was all that good
it was some funny [ __ ]
some of you old timers oh my god
total recall oh my god where they had
the damn scene where arnold
schwarzenegger goes to the [ __ ]
johnny cab and he pulls the [ __ ]
robot out of the front of the johnny cab
he gets in that little bitty [ __ ]
thing and he's going but at least he's
going and he's going and people are
shooting at him
he's in that little thing at least
they're going fast enough to where you
can buy that he's going somewhere
in this particular like yeah we need to
get out here we might be able to outrun
them you know they're shooting at me
there is it is a car-like experience
these [ __ ] pokey knock it off
this shootout happens in between golf
carts that have had body kits put on
them you could literally just step out
of the golf cart and walk alongside the
goddamn golf cart yeah you could jog
maybe not walk but you could jog
alongside the golf course easily easily
and they're they're trying to make it
like a high speed chase with [ __ ]
guns and [ __ ] shooting lasers yeah
and i think they're chasing each other
inside a damn spaceship aren't they well
isn't it a spaceship you say spaceships
support i say
large factory basement yeah it's
supposed to be a spaceship though it's
supposed to be a spaceship it was just
[ __ ] stupid as [ __ ]
no but hilarious there was another movie
where they had something that was kind
of like that in a way but at least they
gave you a sensation of speed
this is another movie i want to get my
hands on we'll do a review on this it
had [ __ ] bruce dern it was
called [ __ ] what was the name of that
[ __ ] movie
silent running
oh that was a good one yeah silent
running that was a good one bruce dern's
in the damn orbital spaceship that has
all these geodesic domes made out of
glass that has the remnants of all the
earth's habitats on it and they got them
up in space to keep them safe because
the earth is so [ __ ] polluted
and he's like an environmentalist he's
[ __ ] bruce dern takes this [ __ ]
seriously he's protecting all these damn
forests and [ __ ] well it is where we
live it's the last of the four well
earth doesn't need them anymore
they don't give a [ __ ] about them and it
runs over budget
and they tell they tell the crews
to go ahead and jettison those damn
things and destroy them with nuclear
warheads and then have spread and have
the ships come back they got important
[ __ ] to pick up you know i mean [ __ ]
that makes money
and during says no [ __ ] that he kills
the rest of the crew to save
the habitats and i think he saved the
desert and the forest and something else
the other ones got blown up
good for brewster yeah
well there's this
and he kills the rest of the crew
there's only two or three guys it was
actually a pretty good movie from what i
remember yeah i remember i liked that i
liked it he killed the other guys and
what he ended up with was these three
little robots with the two legs and it's
actually guys from the vietnam war they
got their legs blown off in the damn
costumes but they were kind of like
believable robots like r2d2 type things
he had three different ones and he
taught him how to take care of all the
[ __ ] well uh he had to move the thing
out towards jupiter to [ __ ] keep the
[ __ ] company from
keeping himself safe from the company to
destroy the [ __ ] but there's a scene
where he's running around inside that
spaceship
in these little six-wheeled
vehicles little all-terrain vehicle
carts
and then the exact same [ __ ] vehicle
that you got
out of the gi joe action set [ __ ]
when gi joe had the six-wheeled vehicle
to go pull the damn mummy out of the
ground and then if you had the damn
egyptian mummy kit like i had
and really what it was is it was a
kind of like a a a precursor to the
three-wheeler
like the honda three-wheeler later on
the four-wheeler was like that so they
had six wheels on them a little bitty
motor and they had them in vietnam or
they the army had some it didn't really
it was like an all-terrain vehicle
and at least those things could go about
35 or 40. and they were chasing each
other around inside the damn spaceship
on those things
and they were trying to recreate that i
think
that's what i think space music honestly
i don't really think they put that much
thought into it because basically this
was a movie they made it in south africa
they're like look we're gonna steal all
the space footage from battlestar
galactica which they did
um and then we're gonna do this whole
thing
with the final chase being essentially
two dudes in
golf carts that are going
maybe five miles an hour and it's
supposed to be this big and exciting
chase
my favorite
scene out of that whole thing
other than red brown who was in some
other movies too he's gonna like a lot
of b movies he was a big like he was a
bodybuilder
and so he was gonna like a lot of b
movies
one of my favorite things even he gets
shot at and he screams like a woman
which is awesome he goes ah like that
kind of thing which is like hilarious
but also
one of the best scenes that i think they
use this is the singer on the mst
episode he's driving the
uh golf cart
thing it's called the enforcer right
don't they call the enforcer or
something like that so it's essentially
a golf cart with like some cardboard
ship built over it so he's driving it
and he's driving it like trying to drive
it into the villain and he's like oh
like he's trying to like this war cry
and then he does that but then like he
he literally goes like this is like ah
okay and then he like like and it's just
like he goes from that to like hey
climbing out of the car just like all
casual and it's like so so funny and
it's like
the fact that they got that on film
every time i see it and i've seen that
episode like a zillion times every time
i see that it like [ __ ] cracks me up
every single day tom the bomb says tom
finally watched david cronenberg's the
brood this evening it was worth the
watch
i love
david cronenberg the brood the brood
was a product of its time
to watch that now it would be cool to
watch it for the first time probably but
there's something about being there as a
[ __ ] kid
in the 80s and seeing that thing when it
was fresh
and just a weirdness that was cronenberg
and i watched that [ __ ] not knowing who
cronenberg was it was just a [ __ ]
weird ass bizarre ass movie
set in a setting with these buildings
that reminded me of california at the
time you know they remember this yeah
with the sideways slanted wood walls and
everything yeah because i feel like a
lot of places have that kind of like hey
we're going to make everything diagonal
oh diagonal just to like change it up
around places where they had horse barns
and horse shows there were a lot of
places that were like that they would
use this like
places that you could rent to hold
seminars and business meetings those
were everywhere around california
i guess they were kind of like business
what would you call that there are
places where businesses could go and
hold sales meetings and seminars just
before the internet you couldn't have a
damn
chat on [ __ ] skype you could use
skype resume or something yeah you had
to go to a location to [ __ ] show a
presentation and [ __ ] yeah
where they filmed a lot of the a lot of
[ __ ] the brood a place where i think
they called them convention centers
yeah i think is what they called them
they still got those nowadays but
usually it's like
in a hotel usually in a hotel now back
in the days it was you could rent them
and it was like a series of like little
theaters that had
seating and
they were kind of trippy and it was
weird they usually kept the [ __ ] kind of
unlocked and they would be near open
areas out in california
outside the main part of the cities
like
my mom one of the one of the places my
mom used to ride was called cota de caza
and they had a place like that right
next to it
and when we were kids we'd go in there
and go look we'd walk around it was like
being in a shopping mall by yourself
there's bunches of them
like there'd be eight or nine of them
yeah and then there's some of them had
bungalows like apartments but they were
always empty
one time we walked in and they were
having a seminar and they go get out of
here and we ran we were kids you know
damn i wonder what the seminar was about
it looked like some kind of sales
seminar they had the damn projector go
on and a bunch of businessmen they
laughed
they were all in suits and [ __ ] i liked
it i i like to imagine that it was maybe
some kind of like weird get-together of
like pedophiles or something but that
that particular scene was kind of like
uh that was real common back in their
late 70s early 80s he probably mid 70s
too
and it was because they didn't have
internet you had to have places to meet
up and they suck a lot of money into
[ __ ] like that and it was a good place
to make a movie
that's where they had his like well
david cronenberg has always been really
fascinated other than his fascination
with
body horror in the sense that something
is invading your body from the outside
of the inside he also had a fascination
with
corporatism
in the sense that it was like taking
over like this kind of
uh corporate
i don't know this kind of corporate like
overlord type of thing was like taking
over people's identities like he has
kind of and his son has that to you
brandon croninberg if you haven't seen
any of his movies he's made a couple
but
they have kind of the same like
predilections i kind of feel like
i don't know man david kronenberg
i loved david kernberg he's easily my
top five favorite directors he's always
makes something
interesting yeah always serpent surfer
he remembers he remembers silent running
he saw when he was a kid
yeah i've seen it yeah i want to get
that on blu-ray see what that seems and
somebody mentioned mike and the
mechanics made that song called silent
running which yeah i kind of feel like
was a lot of people's first exposure to
that movie because it's british yeah no
saturn running was american i think was
it and it had it i thought it didn't
have a canadian i think it had a joan
baez song on it i think it was gentle by
us but the morning after
wouldn't that jump by us there has to be
a morning after i think that in that i
think that was in that movie i don't
remember i haven't seen a long time
i'm old i can't i can't remember
everything i remember a lot of things
but i can't remember anything
i can't believe his hair man i'm looking
at that hair and i'm going man i look
[ __ ] i really i'm going back to
[ __ ] 1978.
you know like sing some winger or
something journey
someday love will find you
someday love will find you
i don't know all the lyrics break those
chains that bind you i could also do
like okay
one night we'll remind you
jesse's girl [ __ ]
well that's no jesse's girl although he
had blackheads actually now this is this
is actually this this is taking me more
to like southern rock
you can do some leonard skinner maybe
like white snake or something yeah maybe
yeah yes or no white snake was actually
actually [ __ ] david coverdale was
more stylish than this this you need
like that's some leonard skinner joe
right there
molly they were a little they were a
little more hippie and the hippie hippie
is kind of looking i was thinking that
this would be more along the lines of
like
oh [ __ ] man
who had hair like this
joe dirt
[ __ ]
no no no no no
kenny rogers this is [ __ ] kenny
ryder's haircut [ __ ] yeah
you know when to hold them know when to
fold them
don't know when to walk away know when
to run
i'm here to count your money
we're sitting at the table
the time enough for counting when the
dealing's done why do we know the words
to that song i don't know you know why
because my mom is super individually
rogers
yeah i grew up here in all ages yeah
this is some kenny rogers [ __ ]
island
you walk into the honky tonk like you're
the [ __ ] you know what i mean you got
the dunlaps disease you got the big old
[ __ ] bell buckle the [ __ ] boot cut
[ __ ] jeans with the [ __ ] little
yeah with brown [ __ ] out and brown
[ __ ]
cowboy boots with the ostrich [ __ ]
toes on them you just need the [ __ ] you
don't talk about that's that that's what
you wear with this
and you got a little skinner t-shirt no
[ __ ] that molly hatchet you got a molly
hatchet t-shirt on yeah concert shirt
yeah yeah molly hatchet go you know go
level down yeah yeah leonard skinner
it's too obvious yeah
and then you got a [ __ ] earring right
and the shit's got a long string a bunch
of feathers
you know what i mean like a roach clip
yeah yeah cause you're cool
holy [ __ ]
you guys
but you guys did not grow up in the
1980s
when i was a kid
how old was i probably nine or ten
and like many nine or ten year olds in
the very early 1980s
uh roller skating rinks were all the
[ __ ] right so you go to the roller
skating rink you have your birthday
parties there that's where you met all
your friends what not
so you go there they're playing all the
80s hits they're playing journey they're
playing the j giles band
you know all that kind of stuff and you
had to have
your
head your headband which was like kind
of braided i had it i had several
different ones
i had one that was kind of braided like
pink
that had like the ridge clip on it that
had the clip on it that had gray
feathers on it
also had one that was kind of like red
and white braided and then it had like
red wooden blue feathers on it
um also
had
leg warmers
uh that were gray had the calvin klein
leg warmers
gray you put them over your skates yeah
[ __ ] you were the [ __ ] i was nine
um
[ __ ] you were the [ __ ]
you're out there like
yeah
dan like skating to like centerfold or
whatever jacob's bandsaw was on
or uh
john cougar
tina's trying to get me to sing [ __ ]
rod stewart
if you think
excited if you think i'm sexy it's not
ministry it's not bad
i can't do that voice i can't this is
the revival cox did the revolting [ __ ]
it's really good i tell you what though
as ludicrous as [ __ ] rod stewart was
[ __ ] could sing he sounded [ __ ]
great he had a very good voice
i didn't really like the material that
that much you know even in the day
it was catchy
but it was
just he could sing though he had a he
had a cool [ __ ] voice i appreciate it
now more than i
did back in the day because like i said
back in this back in the early 80s
he was kind of hoarse
i was kind of well that was what was on
the radio yeah it's like and you didn't
really
you weren't really into that you were
kind of more into what was on mtv
or what was on like college radio yeah
uh or at least i was like back in the
80s so it's kind of like
you know you heard all that stuff
because your parents were listening to
it
but
you were kind of like so you knew it but
it was just kind of like yeah this is
not really i was always on the
impression that rod stewart was gay but
i don't think he was but at the time i
thought he was
no absolutely not yeah i don't think so
either absolutely looking back on it but
at the time i thought he was
esther says i grew up in the 80s jenny i
graduated high school in 1986.
good well you're yeah you're a little
bit older than me then i graduated high
school in 1990 so i'm a couple years
behind you
but yeah it's yeah the same kind of tila
tila you like that song go ahead and
open another window and [ __ ] go on
youtube
and [ __ ]
search for a band called the revolting
[ __ ]
and [ __ ]
it's like a super group that was like
al jorgensen from ministry it was like a
couple other people
and they did a cover of
and it's if you think i'm sexy right and
then if you think i'm sexy yeah it's
funny and it's actually better than the
original i think
i mean but that's just it's kind of kind
of a [ __ ] industrial version of it
and every time i hear that song which is
kind of often because i have it on my
phone
every like he changed the words to like
modernize him a little bit so every time
he says because i think in the original
song he says something like he give me a
dime so i can call my mother or
something like that in the remake he
says give me a buck so i can buy a
rubber
which you know what i mean so but he
also your heart's beating like a drum
cause at last you got this girl home but
there's one part in the song relax with
the darling right no no relax baby relax
baby no
but there comes a point in the song
where he says
you know they're gonna go out like
whatever and he's like he says i'm sorry
but i'm out of ky yes sorry because and
al jorgensen like laughs yeah yeah and
they left it in yeah
every time i hear that it cracks me up
every single time even though i know
it's coming because it's like i'm sorry
but i'm out of ky jelly yeah uh
never mind sugar let's see the early
movie i think he says yeah yeah and it's
just like every time i hear that it like
cracks me he's checking the revolted
[ __ ]
actually everything that i've heard from
the revolting [ __ ] is really good well
they did beer stairs and queers beers
stairs and queers that's another
they were a superband made up of all the
[ __ ] industrial bands
yeah like i said it was a well i can't
even remember like it was al jorgensen
from ministry and like a couple like who
the [ __ ] else was it martin atkins it
was like some other it was some other
people from all like the [ __ ]
industrial like all the people are on
wax tracks back in the day
and uh they formed a super group and
they did well did you just ask you are
in for a treat
al jorgensen diagnose it didn't he also
have the 1000 homo dj's side project
which did the cover of super knot
uh which
honestly that's still one of my favorite
dance songs of all time
like the cover of black sabbath's like
supernova yeah yeah uh which is really
really good
um so i will still every time they play
that i'll still dance to it and honestly
even nowadays this many years later if
somebody plays like beerus years and
queers
still got an answer yeah yeah dj maniac
says is pretty much everyone from
ministry martin atkins started picking
oh i got that yeah that's right that's
right that's right and another ministry
cover ban okay mm-hmm
yeah yeah they were all like trading
members cuts from tom and jenny right
right that was a well we remember we
remember all this stuff a thousand homos
dj's one thousand one thousand homos
dj's ai and trent and paul and bill yeah
yeah
it was a good bad and and all their [ __ ]
is still very danceable and they play it
all the time with the [ __ ] clubs we
go to all their still to this day
i think the last time we were at
mannequins
i think he played barristers
to be honest with you yeah and that was
just a couple weeks ago so they're still
like playing it
just saying and i wouldn't be i am the
creator i wouldn't
squeeze
beers and steers and queers yeah
yeah that a boy
you guys can check that one up too
revolting [ __ ] beers and steers and
queens there's a bunch of different
mixes but the one they usually play at
the club is usually the best one it's
like i had a um i had a maxi single if
you guys remember what that is but it's
like my dad my dad's in the chat tom's
dad turkey
[Laughter]
man i need another drink for this
if your dad's showing up yeah my dad's
in the comments are the turkey necks
inside you yeah how's that going
oh my god you guys
but yeah so
yeah it's funny because it's like i know
you say deep cuts but it's like for us
for me it doesn't really seem like deep
cuts
because
i had all the even though it's not my
it's not my preferred genre i'm gonna
say i'm more like a punk rock death rock
goth rock
kind of girl
but
um you know i'm not
that much of an industrial girl but i do
like kind of
shade over into that
so
the fact that i mean when i was growing
up that was kind of like
i had a friend that was like super super
into like pig face and all that all that
stuff so it's like
you know back in the day
when i was
broke while i'm still bringing the ghost
he says i'm sorry but i'm out of ky
jelly
yeah yeah yeah yeah every single time
and then he laughs and then like that
he's like
like he's like and then they kept it
they kept that take and it's like every
time that [ __ ] that [ __ ] check out
beers and stairs and queers
that's another good one and queer yeah
beers and stairs i mean it's about
deliverance
and it's
every time they play it at mannequins it
could particularly it kind of like makes
me laugh because
it's making fun of rednecks
but i think that rednecks listen to it
and like think it's like celebrating
them to some extent which like kind of
makes me laugh
you know what i mean
because it is
it's no it's about deliverance that song
it's
it's based on delivering she's asking to
go in the closet why do you well no
she's like no it's a problem let her go
in the closet okay there's nothing in
there oh no where we going where are we
going now where are we going now we're
supposed underneath the chair
i can't fit underneath the chair what
are you doing
she's like what you're too big for
underneath the chair
she's like well you suck then yeah poor
pokey
she doesn't understand that we're too
big to like follow her in certain places
but if she wants to go in the closet she
can go in the closet she didn't want to
go there's nothing all that upsetting
why'd you put those pillows there like
that
that's just where this is well i saw
that earlier and i thought that you were
because you put those pillows there like
that when you're when you're shooting um
you know uh a screen yeah for the show
for the shirts like to keep the lights
out and i thought you were doing that
and i was just kind of like what the
hell it was just random that's just
where i put them
oh [ __ ] here we go
here we go
michael caine is now
now in the [ __ ] building is he
[ __ ] you yeah
may i ask you something my darling is he
[ __ ] you is he [ __ ] you are you
[ __ ] him
are you [ __ ] him
sure
okay yeah
[ __ ] great movie man
dj maniac says super knot was my
bathroom bathroom-breaking cigarette
song yeah it's very long
i kind of feel like
i was kind of feel like
djs always have these songs that are
like okay well this is like nine or ten
minutes long so it's like i could put
this on
and then like go to the can
i'm gonna put on bella lugosi's dead
which is like nine plus minutes long and
i'm just gonna go to the bathroom oh you
got the light severed handed everything
we're doing the whole she's asking where
the hand is we're doing the whole the
full monty yeah this evening
[Laughter]
pookie loves that hand
i told you earlier she was trying to
like pull it off the shelf but she's
also kind of scared of it
[Laughter]
this is my smart wig they said this is
my smart wig when i get smart
is it that's what they said
no smart wig i'll believe it when i see
it
no your smart wig is like your mozart
wig yeah yeah i know you want to call it
like your your founding father away i
found it it's the white boy wig but i
kind of like i still kind of feel like
that's your team [ __ ] called it she's
going that's what real white boys
[ __ ] wore was that damn wig the
genuine thing
it had to be a blue blood
say
you look like a you see them damn blue
veins see
there's a white boy wig everyone's veins
are blue if their skin is white enough
just letting well there you go
there you go
man it must be nice to like be a dude
where you can even have you could have
you don't even have to wear makeup for
one thing you don't have to wear a bra
which is another thing um and your hair
can look all [ __ ] up because look at
like benjamin franklin
you know he's like [ __ ] bald but he
has like the [ __ ]
growth in the back he's like look i'm
just gonna slap a wig over this and
everything's fine
everything's fine you just walk out your
house yeah
wow he said the hand was an amazing
movie yes it is it is it is a [ __ ]
great oliver stone movie i mean it's so
good and i feel like a lot of people
haven't seen it like i said it's oliver
stone's it's his first movie yeah
his first directing i don't know if it
was his first movie but it um it was an
early one of course
and we grew up with it
and
conan being one of my favorite movies
there's a lot of crossover between the
hand and conan and it's because
john millius and oliver stone
were both kind of working on conan
but milius ended up with getting conan
even though stone wrote some of the
early
scripts for it you know
well in the hand they talk about
um
a cartoon character what was his name
[ __ ]
he was kind of like conan yeah but they
weren't calling him that no they
couldn't call him they they couldn't do
it was it con
no it started with an m
uh mandrel right mandrake mandrel
yeah mandrel
mandrel was conan
and the whole idea okay look now
well wait a minute before you get into
that okay let me ask you
have you seen
the first movie that john millius
directed
dillinger no uh because
welcome to the basement yeah who i i
love that channel um that's blame
society if you guys don't know they also
do beer and board games
they just did dillinger this past week
uh they loved it and they thought it was
like it's like way more they said that
it was like way more violent than like
sam pekinpah or like you know bonnie
clyde or whatever but it came out around
the same time as that
and
i had forgotten that that was the first
movie that john milley is he had done
screenwriting prior to that but this was
the first one that he directed and i so
i wondered if you had seen it
it looked like something that you would
really really believe into
yeah what i was going to say was is that
stone and milius kana
they were friends and they worked on a
lot of [ __ ] together
conan was about masculinity healthy
masculinity
nowadays people go how is that healthy
but you gotta [ __ ] it's it's it it's
a
conan was a [ __ ] awesome his version
of conan was awesome character awesome
story about
human development not only in men but in
women
because conan had a mate basically she
died though but everything is
all
i'm going to say symbolic everything is
legendary he's teaching something
through a mythical tale
that was
healthy masculinity
the hand
was the opposite and it refers to conan
mandro what they call him
but the particular dude who [ __ ]
makes mandro
it's about toxic masculinity yeah
because that dude is like the worst it's
about not letting go a [ __ ]
who's trying to possess some [ __ ] with
his hand
his
basically he's kind of almost kind of
like an incel he has sex but it's not
enough he's got a [ __ ]
capture [ __ ]
and she's
woman wants to leave him and instead of
just letting her go like is the right
thing to do
the hand takes over which is it's either
symbolic or it's something like
poltergeist
phenomenon where his subconscious of
powers are killing people who are in his
way it's difficult to know it's open to
interpretation is he doing or is the
hand doing it
it could be either
i like to think that it's the hand it
probably isn't though it's probably him
doing it
i kind of feel like it's him
well the movie wouldn't be as fun
if you say but like i said
when you kind of ambiguous yeah and when
it comes to horror particularly uh the
hand which i really really like i really
like ambiguous right you could read it
either way yeah like you could either
watch it as this is a
uh lim ghana muk story which you could
see it like that or you could see it
like a symbolic thing it's like the hand
is imaginary and it's just doing
what he wants to do
and he's like dissociating sophie
watched the movie and she got back to me
she liked it she goes the thing is
though she was a [ __ ] though
his wife was a [ __ ] it's like yeah she
was not well a little bit but not that
much she was but that doesn't give you a
right to kill her that's what i yeah all
right that is she and honestly from my
point of view she didn't seem like that
much of a [ __ ] um you know what i mean
she wasn't a [ __ ] [ __ ] she just she
was unfaithful to him she fooled around
on him well and and the fact is
he distanced himself
from him well the thing about it is that
he kind of didn't leave her much of a
choice he didn't have a choice he was
trying to he was so possessive that she
had the right choice but to be that's
what i'm saying she was kind of like
look that i'm showing you like i want
this i want that and he was just like
yeah i don't want to do that so she's
like well [ __ ] off i'm just going to
kind of call it kind of called it though
she wasn't really confronting the issue
and trying to make a clean break
i said the thing is is though that he
was kind of so hot tempered and violent
it could be that she could felt it was
unsafe
to [ __ ] that's what i'm saying well
she did
say yeah look i want this that the other
thing you're gonna get and then he was
like yeah no we're not doing that and
like he just shut her down right at
which point she's like okay well if i
try to leave this [ __ ] is going to try
to kill me
the the the thing the thing that soph
said which pointed it out is well they
were already married and they had a kid
together
but the thing is is that this was
happening during during a time and i'm a
product of this generation
a lot of people got married pretty young
and they were getting divorced while
their children were still young and that
was pretty common because they had
married the people that didn't
that didn't really matter
i mean my parents married when they were
what 19. well they were coming out of a
basically a 1950 they had me right out
of i hate high school yeah they were
coming out of a 1950s mentality yeah
where you got married [ __ ] right
after your senior year of high school
and immediately sold yourself
to a [ __ ] company that would take
care of you for the rest of your life
like something out of japan well that
was long gone
by the time the [ __ ] 80s and the 70s
had rolled around
by the time me and graham got out of
high school that was a distant dream
there was no thing where you could be a
company man for the rest of your life
the companies would throw you away well
it's like
that [ __ ] was gone as relatively short
as human lives are
you don't want that anyway
well you don't want to like you get out
of high school at 18. yeah um and if you
go to college you get out of college at
like 22 23 you know whatever unless
you're going to like you know
post-doctoral stuff but it's kind of
like you go to that and it's just kind
of like is that really what you want to
do like your whole life it's like
seriously you could do that for 20 years
and it's like yeah i'm sick of this [ __ ]
and it's like i'm going to go do
something else now so i kind of feel
like
i don't know this kind of like weird 50s
ideal of you're gonna marry this person
when you're
18 or 22 or whatever you're gonna have
this job for like your whole life that
is like the most depressing thing that
i've ever heard heard of yeah
no need for me too says that he that he
believed the hand was doing it
all right uh and it scared the [ __ ] out
of me as
a kid i think the head was doing it
certain things happened in the movie i
think he was imagining the hand it's
ambiguous certain things happen but i
like that they leave it ambiguous
there's certain things happened in the
movie where the hand had to have done it
the thing is is that in a way
he's kind of the narrator of the story
he's not a reliable narrator that's what
i'm saying so you just don't know
but what it does is the one guy he kills
over the woman the one he strangles in
the car that he meets at the bar his
friend he kills his own friend over a
woman it was a basically a one-night
stand really
in a way she was she was just a flame
and she well she was like a student of
his student and she was sleeping with a
lot of people during a time of free love
type of deal anyway and she just wanted
to split um like i said she was just
banging him cuz yeah she could it's like
and he got all like [ __ ] got he got
kind of clean he caught feelings about
it but um
he said some stuff about the power of
the subconscious mind
okay
and this all kind of this was a gestalt
that was around when i was a kid in a
formative years
which
being in california and just things in
my family that had happened and things
that people believed in my family
um
i was always open to the idea that there
were
like psychic abilities
and that telekinesis might have been
possible and then i had that damn
poltergeist experience i saw this movie
before the poltergeist
but it makes me wonder if movies like
this contributed to me psyching myself
up to that
might have been and there's there's
in the time when i was a kid there were
parapsychologists around that were still
pretty respected some of them like carl
young and stuff that believed things
like this could happen
and that they believed it did happen and
poultry guys was one of them i'd never
heard of that at that time poetry guys
i'd heard of the word but i didn't know
what it meant
it wasn't something in the
in the common vernacular
faith and belief
and high levels of [ __ ] kind of like
i guess stress family stress seems to
[ __ ] cause things like that
rspk recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
i don't
i had it happen to me jenny's seen it
knit here later on in my life it it it
is something that does happen
it is not something that can be
controlled as far as i can tell it's not
something you could use
in a military situation it's not
something you could use for gain
you would think that you could be able
to steal a lot of money
but there's something about the way the
subconscious works i think you don't
allow yourself to do it
well i've told him prior i'm like look
if i can if you can do that uh you know
steal some money out of like a bank
vault or something yeah and do it yeah
it doesn't do it probably because of the
certain safeguards having to do with the
ego
and i don't think you could do
maybe i'm wrong
but i i have a feeling that you can't do
what you see darth vader doing like
choking somebody while they're alive i
don't think it's possible because other
people have wills too
and you know what i mean they have kind
of that same
life force that's within them that would
prevent that i believe
it seems to be inanimate objects moving
that don't have a big repercussion on
anything
in other words they can't change the
course of anybody's life
it's it's almost like you don't allow it
it's what it seemed like well because
seriously if you try to like some
supernatural [ __ ] on me i'd be like
well i think certain instincts don't i
think certain instincts inside of people
don't allow it but maybe i'm wrong maybe
these tales about witches and [ __ ]
maybe they come from
somebody who can do that and hurt a
person with it man were the people were
the people in the middle ages being
killed as a witches guilty of that no of
course not
no jesus christ no they were just
picking random people
well they were killing people that they
wanted to get they wanted
now
out of those thousands and thousands of
people that they killed
was that was that belief maybe based on
the phenomena that they saw maybe
maybe maybe they saw a poltergeist and
maybe they but like i said we're not
victim blaming because it's like no they
were killing innocent people based upon
something that they saw once with
somebody else
and they maybe they read into it
because
reports of ghosts go all the way back to
the roman period
yeah
you know seeing visions
visions of dead relatives
uh
feelings the presence
of the devil well i feel like a lot of
people have uh seen that and honestly
from my point of view
i don't really know
i mean like i said look i'm an atheist i
don't believe in an afterlife or any of
that kind of stuff
but there have
been a lot of reports of people that
specifically
um have seen
their
relatives like come back and tell them
[ __ ]
i don't know
and i don't know if that's something
outside of them
or if they're just
or if that's just like some stressful
[ __ ] that you know because they're going
through the grief because look i've lost
family members that i loved
and
if i could have seen them one more time
and they were like talking to me that
would have been like really cool i never
did
but
maybe
somebody that was more
i hate to use this word but maybe
somebody was more suggestible than me
um would have seen them and it's like
would have told them stuff
um
you know when my grandfather died
many of my
uh aunts
and my mom
said that they
saw him
in their dreams
uh or saw him other places and they and
that he told them things
but
i don't know i it's hard to like kind of
parse out because i don't know
if that's just you
i don't know if that's just wishful
thinking
or if it's like something or if it's
something objective it's or if it's
something outside yourself because
that's that's why i'm like really
skeptical of like people's
um
[Music]
uh you know kind of stories about
particularly like seeing relatives like
after they die and stuff like that
because i do kind of feel like that's
you know it's in your favor
if you want to put it that way
to
see them after like to get some closure
um
you know
so
i don't know i
i don't know i i just feel bad about it
because i know some people like have a
thing
if i could have seen my grandma
let's let's give an example because i
loved my grandma i lived with her many
years when i was growing up
uh when she died i was like really
really upset
and
i was pretty [ __ ] up like for a year
or two after she died so
if i could have seen her after she died
that would have like really but i never
did but i don't know if that was because
i'm just like a skeptical [ __ ] i
don't know i never saw it most people
most people don't have any visions of
the dead they just don't
i see her in my dreams a lot well i
dream about her okay well then
i dream about her i dream about her
house
me i
i had a near-death experience and
out-of-body experience that wasn't in
that near-death experience and no i i
have a feeling that at least for a while
the dead that have been disincarnate
will be able to contact for a while
once they kind of merge with the
constant consciousness they vanish i
think they won't be able to come back
it's kind of like dropping a drop of
water into the ocean that drop is now
gone it's part of the ocean it's like
that i mean in a way i kind of hope that
but some people seem to be
when i was out of body i felt that if i
wanted to contact this living person i
would be able to whether or not they'd
accept the communication probably not
they probably reject it
i mean if there was something after
where everybody just kind of like goes
in this big consciousness
yeah i would kind of more hope
that my grandma did that i don't want to
like hanging around no
i had this like terrible
i had this like really creepy and it's
like i can't really like get across to
you but it's like i have this nightmare
everything like a few months back
where because i dream a lot about my
grandmother's house because i lived
there for a long time and i hung out
with my grandmother a lot when she was
uh you know and when she was dying and
stuff like that
so
i kind of feel like i have a lot of
dreams about her house i had this
horrible nightmare
where
i was in the house and it's like she was
i kind of expected her to be there but
she wasn't and then like i went outside
the house into the street and it was
just like the street like
you know
like it was in real life
but it was night time and i went out and
i knew
in the dream that
nobody
was there like everybody was dead
and it was kind of like it was almost
kind of like i was in the afterlife and
like no one was around and it was like
this really
depressing dream and i remember like
being bummed out when i woke up and i
was kind of like
i kind of hope that
if there's some kind of afterlife i hope
she's not hanging around
in that because it's like it it just
really really bummed me all right as i
say if you guys want to know what i feel
or what i saw
about the paranormal in terms of out of
body experience in near death
it was all covered and shown out of that
goofy michael j fox movie the
frighteners
if you watch that movie
that's basically what i saw now was it
that goofy no
was it that much of it all in one place
like you go to a graveyard and there's
all these dead people no no it's not but
a lot of the problems why would you hang
out yeah
they're not they're not hanging out but
the principles of what i saw
when i when i went out of body or had
the near-death experience were right
there outlined in that movie and i'm not
the only one that's basically the same
generic
feeling that or experience everybody
else has now some people will say well
it's your body dying oxygen out no i
don't believe you knew that at no time
was i
my brain starved of oxygen
and then there's a lot of people that
doctors who saw what happened with a
person who's dying and they've said no
it couldn't have been that they had no
brain activity at all
so they were dead you know when all this
was going on but then they could
remember what the doctors said
after the person was dead with no brain
activity
so no it now can you be out of body a
disincarnate spirit for long i don't
think so
you couldn't do it for long
i don't think
you have to go one place or another
eventually
and that's in that movie frighteners
they they talk about that
so i think whoever kind of wrote up that
script either imagined it correctly
or they based that story
on things that people said they saw
but it
pretty much matched up in general
to what my experiences were is that that
seems pretty much what i saw it seemed
like that
that's one of my favorite movies
frighteners which bombed at the box
office great movie though especially the
uh
the the longer cut that's on the blu-ray
it has all the extra scenes in it
i mean honestly i'm kind of like
i don't know haven't gone through the
experience of watching my grandmother
die who like i said was
one of my favorite people in the whole
world still is actually
and
man
she got cancer like i said she had
stomach cancer
and after a time like when they found
out hey we're gonna like have to take
this that and the other she was like you
know what [ __ ] it just let me die i'm
not doing
all the um you know she didn't want to
do all this [ __ ] like to try to get rid
of it
she was like you know what just send me
back home give me a bed
i'm not
doing it
she was kind of over it
and she was like an awesome person
and
i don't know it's just kind of like
she got sent to like a uh you know
hospice in the end
and she wanted a coma she was only coma
for a day or two and then she passed
away
and
i don't know man it's like the fact of
i kind of feel like if it was her
because she was the kind of person she
was a little bit like me in a lot of
ways
where she was just kind of like i don't
she wasn't like into all the [ __ ]
she's kind of like look is anything
going on okay i'm out
so i kind of feel like she just would
have if there was something to go on to
she would have just been like yeah [ __ ]
this i'm out of here yeah she wouldn't
like that because even when she was
alive she was kind of like why are they
prolonging this it's like i don't
know what i mean once once you're kind
of out of body
time and time space becomes irrelevant
so from the point of view of a person
who's outside their body
waiting around for 50 or 60 years that's
nothing
so why would they contact you
well see that's what i kind of feel like
well that's why i don't really
i'm not a big believer in like kind of
goose kind of [ __ ] in the sense that
a ghost as an intelligent being
that's hanging around for like hundreds
of years trying to like
pass some like information on it's like
why would anyone hang around for a
couple years why would anyone do that
there might be an echo of the past
that's what i'm saying if that exists
which i'm not sure is true but if that
exists it's like i feel like that's just
like a [ __ ] echo in the past you're
yeah seeing right i don't think that's
there's any you might have some kind of
like a psychic clairvoyant sense where
you can sense something that happened
and you and you're kind of seeing it as
a three-dimensional hologram
it's probably mostly in your mind
you see it it might seem to be a
three-dimensional person standing there
but if you were to take a picture of it
there wouldn't be anything there and
maybe somebody else might be standing
right next to you they may not see it
you know
it may not be there objectively it might
just be there subjectively
what do you say
thank you david june where all the super
chats at i don't know where the super
chats are i don't know we'll find out
how long we've been streaming
uh
three hours oh [ __ ] it's about time then
no i'm just saying that it's like you
mean no
no
i said it's three hours because
i know but i was still talking okay
so i'm just letting you know
getting late
i can see it okay i know how long you've
been talking all right
eat this up
you can't even see he's right you don't
have glasses i don't where is it you're
looking where is it you're looking right
there
live
three hours
two minutes oh i see it
okay
i was always wondering where it was
right there all right
this is like submarine control yeah
controls on a goddamn submarine it's all
nothing but just lines and numbers
everywhere
i couldn't really see him
yeah well yeah
and then but he like pretends like
i'm some crazy person that she's like
walking like well i know i'm a crazy
person
but
don't listen to her she's always talking
[ __ ]
what i'm crazy anyway i'm crazy in a fun
way no it's okay go ahead what are you
saying no i was just saying that it's
like
it's really weird like
i kind of feel like my grandmother
bobby jean
i kind of feel like when she died
she was kind of like
the first person that had died that was
like super super close to me like i had
other people die like my uncle died of
cancer when he was like in his 30s so
other people had you know that that had
happened before
but
oh [ __ ] it's a dancing way thank you
you're [ __ ] pretty man i put this on
all the fans love this one yeah
but i kind of feel like when she died
that was kind of like
i don't know she was like in a lot of
ways she was kind of like i don't want
to see she was like my mom because i
love my mom
but she was like my second mom
um
you know i
i grew up there like a long time so when
she died it was like this really weird
i don't know it was really weird and i
kind of like got into this place where
i was kind of like
i don't know i remember being in my
house
in the early 2000s like a year or two
after she died
and i was kind of like
i don't know if you you guys no
seriously gonna get to the point
[Laughter]
she's been you've been drinking no go
ahead now what what point did you get to
no what i'm saying is that anybody
that's lost a loved one
i kind of feel like you get to a point
where
do you feel like you're not allowed
to be
happy because that person's dead
like i kind of feel like people that
have like lost a loved one like you
maybe you know what i'm talking about
so i kind of got to a point where it's
like
i kind of felt like well i can't be
happy because she's gone you know what i
mean and it's like i kind of felt like i
couldn't be happy
and then i remember like one day
i was at my house and this like back in
like 2008 2009 something like that
and i was like putting laundry where i
was like you know what
i was like
she wouldn't want me to
be like this
you know what i mean where it's like
it's where you can't be happy because
she's dead
you know what i mean yes
you know what i'm saying yeah
you are a useless person what are you
talking about what do you want me to say
i said yeah i know i know something do
you know what i'm talking about oh yeah
yeah
um have you ever experienced that uh no
okay well has anybody else ever
experienced that no because i'm kind of
over like asking i'm really excited i
just don't know have you ever
experienced anything yeah where it's
kind of like you feel like you're not
allowed to
be normal or like be happy
because that person's gone no it's like
you kind of have to like allow yourself
yeah
to
move on
yeah you know what i'm saying it's like
but you feel it but you feel bad about
it okay i can imagine what you're
talking about but no i haven't felt that
but like i anytime but i'm sure a lot of
people know what i'm talking about right
but i kind of feel like felt like i like
that and it's like i kind of like it
kind of came to me in like this
revelation
okay
one day and like i said i remember it i
remember because i was like putting
laundry where someone looks i remember
the laundry basket being on the bed and
i was kind of like
man
she would not want me to like my whole
life just like
be like feel bad about being happy
because she was dead you know what i'm
saying it's like you really have to kind
of like put that aside
but it's weird because i never saw her
as a ghost
nothing like that i would have loved
that honestly because she was awesome
but
i have a lot of dreams about her though
i have i have a lot of dreams about her
i have a dream a lot of dreams about her
house
every time i have a weird dream it's
always in her house yeah
which is still there like other people
live in it now yeah but
what are you laughing at nothing nothing
you talk about it xanada says tom
doesn't have empathy yeah i know i have
empty no you don't
but he also was talking about how
hammered you are
well i know i'm hammered but it's like
okay thank you for pointing that out
because he really he really does not no
i just no i just never felt that i i
don't see how i just don't see things
that way but i can understand how other
people do because you don't care about
other people or no it's just that i have
a different view on life and death i
guess
i expect that death is going to happen
victor said maybe you need a ouija board
yeah i don't i have one but
i don't know
i kind of feel like if my grandma was
still around she probably would have
[ __ ] off by now yeah she seems like
the kind of person that was just like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah she'd be out of here
she'd be like me i'd be like why would
the [ __ ] would i hang out i wouldn't
hang out
just saying all right so
let's see what everybody's talking about
it's getting kind of [ __ ]
down in the dumps jenny
xander said i don't have dreams at all
yeah i think that's very unhealthy
i have dreams also but
i don't know i don't have like as weird
dreams as i used to most of the dreams i
have nowadays like i said are about dead
people or about places that
i used to live it's a very strange
either that or i have dreams about
[ __ ] that i have to do the next day
which is depressing
you know
it's depressing
i don't have that i don't have time to
have that many dreams because you keep
waking me up every couple hours of your
snoring all right t we'll see you later
we'll see you on friday t's leaving
oh [ __ ] man what shit's good
all right welcome to my world
what'd you say
no i'm just saying with your hair catch
on
i was like yeah
yeah camp guy says smoking weed makes me
stop dreaming yeah
hmm
maybe i should do that
all right i'm getting tired jen let's go
ahead and shut it down you sure yeah i'm
getting tired
you gonna make me some food yeah i'll
make some food
feed me see more
all right well it's sucking uh stream
went on for uh what nearly three hours
three and a half hours probably hours we
will see you guys in a minute we will
see you guys friday uh like share and
subscribe and thank you for joining
tonight oh i'm excited about the friday
show yeah the friday night it's gonna be
on friday we're talking about because a
couple people
zack among them uh suggested that we do
a show about rosemary kennedy or francis
farmer so i decided to do
a whole women in mental health history
of hysteria okay kind of show all right
all that like wandering womb [ __ ] okay
we're talking about all that oh my god
that's good
when a [ __ ] jumps out just goes around
like a ghost [ __ ] okay
we'll talk about that
like it's it's funny but it's not funny
we'll see what we'll see
[Laughter]
i mean like i said it's funny but
in a way it's not funny because
yeah
but you know we're going to talk about
rosemary kennedy we're going to francis
farmer we're going to talk about nelly
bly we're gonna talk about all kind of
cool [ __ ] okay it'll be super fun all
right honoring wombs all right we're
gonna talk about crazy [ __ ] go ahead
we'll uh we'll see you guys
we're gonna talk about crazy [ __ ] on
friday we will see you guys then we're
gonna go ahead and sign out for now you
guys have a good night
bye-bye good night you guys we will see
you friday night
bye